The joe rogan experience.
Try My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Right?
I can't tell ya how many times on this podcast we've talked about growing your
own food,
about how great it would be if people figured out a way to utilize like empty
spaces in neighborhoods or a lot on a block and put in a garden and then boom,
somebody sent me a link to your Ted talk and I said,
Ron Finley is on it.
You're on it.
And you've been doing this for a while.
Tell me,
tell me how you got started in this.
It was real simple.
Ain't no damn food where I live,
you know?
So my thing was,
if it ain't there,
you put it there.
It's,
I mean,
I,
and I,
I think these neighborhoods are by design.
I think this whole food system is to me,
a form of slavery for everybody.
You know?
And I think a lot of people don't get it.
They want to control your life.
And if you control the food,
you can draw with a word.
Do you think it's by design where someone's set out and said,
okay,
we want to take these people and we want to keep them impoverished.
We're going to keep them ignorant and want to keep them in this,
this cycle of crime and poverty with no escape?
Or do you think it's convenient for them to ignore it because they don't get any
benefit on trying to make it better?
They do get a benefit is so much money being raped from these communities there.
It's not that they're poor.
I mean,
to me it's all by design.
It's too perfect of a storm.
Not to be by design.
The fact that you have what,
four corners,
but you have six fast food restaurants.
These restaurants are not making no money.
Bullshit.
You know,
it's,
it's like in the school system.
Come on.
I'm sure you've been in the schools,
Joe.
Yeah.
Till you can't tell me that's not by design.
You can't tell me the food they're eating in these schools from day one.
Isn't that,
you know,
it's garbage,
is definitely garbage.
But I always felt like it was more of an opportunistic thing than a by design
thing.
Like it's very,
um,
it's very fun to sit around and think about like the cabal of Illuminati that
controls the world and like to break that down into and to get all the way down
to urban neighborhoods and to think about it.
Like it's by design that these neighborhoods are the way they are.
Um,
but I always wonder how much of it is actually just people taking advantage of
people who are in a situation when there's no other options where they don't
have anything better until a guy like you comes along.
Oh,
I'm,
I'm one person,
but yeah,
but you're one person with a message and that's all it takes some time.
Yeah,
it's,
it's crazy that I'm,
that I'm even here.
I mean,
how I'm here,
it's,
I didn't plan that it is,
you know,
and all of a sudden,
I plant a seed in the ground and shit in Greece.
I mean,
cut a,
I'm an old man.
I'm,
I'm in England,
you know,
from,
from planting the seed.
In the ground and south central so it's everywhere.
Right
Joe,
you know what I'm saying?
That's how it works.
Sometimes it just takes someone to do something and everybody goes,
oh yeah,
exactly.
That's what's happening.
When I was a kid,
my stepdad was a part of this community garden thing.
Like it was,
he was going to college and there was this,
um,
this thing that they would do with a class where they would have,
everybody would have shifts,
you know,
they would have to take care of the garden.
And I remember thinking like,
what a great idea.
Like this is a,
it was amazing idea.
Like why shouldn't everybody grow their own food if you just,
we have one lot,
one lot.
If there's a hundred houses on a block,
one lot is just gardens.
You got everybody's food right there.
Because if you do that,
you're destroying the system.
Come on.
I mean,
that's what it is.
They just can't,
why is it illegal to plant food?
That's where it gets weird.
Weird,
right?
Joe,
tell me how illegal it is,
but I'm saying weird in that like how,
how are the laws written?
Like what,
what is illegal?
Well,
I'm now the laws in La have been changed,
you know,
say thank you guys too,
because of these nails in my hands,
you know,
from,
from me being put up on that on the wall.
But um,
a lot of places it's still against the law.
And why would it be against the law to grow food,
you know?
Um,
that's what I'm saying about this,
this whole slavery thing,
man.
Well it's,
it's a suburban thing too.
There was some folks,
was it Detroit or where was it?
Where they got arrested for uh,
for having chickens?
Yeah,
so I think it was Illinois.
I don't remember him,
but these people just had a normal like backyard chicken coop.
Where's it?
Michigan,
Michigan.
And they got arrested.
They went to fucking jail for having chickens.
When I first did,
when I first put my garden on my parkway,
I mean,
I literally got a warrant.
This is the time you saw is not the first time.
That's the second time because I guess I'm kinda thick,
like the Italians say,
you know,
uh,
he don't get it.
Uh,
but yeah,
no,
I got it.
I had to go to court,
you know,
twice to make sure,
hey,
get it out,
you know,
take this out.
You can only have this and this.
If some guy says you can,
well,
you can keep the trees.
I kept the trees and somebody came back,
you're getting cited for the trees.
Take,
I said,
take everything out.
Why Dude?
There's,
there's,
there's nothing to eat around here and you,
and you're going to,
I'm going to get penalized.
I have a strip of land is that usually people leave their dressers and trash and
condoms and toilets and sinks and shit on the,
on the,
on the parkway and all of a sudden I beautify it and it's like,
oh no,
this is against the law to have beauty out here,
dude.
You can't do that.
So did they find you when you were planting these things or did someone,
somebody called a neighbor called and um,
motherfuckers
grown blew it and that's it.
But that's,
it's cool because I tell people to embrace your haters because they make you
famous.
You know?
Cause the next thing I know,
I'm on a 27 floor suite overlooking the harbor in Vancouver about to do the
first ted I got did the got,
that took me to the big Ted,
you know,
so,
so it was,
it was,
it was kind of weird.
I never forget this moment man.
I was looking in the window looking out at the Harvard and you know,
so I saw my reflection in the window and I'm like,
Damn Dude,
you standing here because of some hater.
You know,
you're in another country and some damn sweet because of somebody tried to get
you in trouble,
you know,
planting carrots.
Well that's sort of the,
someone getting mad at you sorta put energy into it.
It made it more,
more vital.
Made the whole thing there was more behind it,
right?
Yeah,
totally.
Because,
because I think a lot of people woke up and saw this is the shit is stupid.
You know,
what,
why,
why are you disguise beautifying his neighborhood,
you know,
it's not costing you anything.
And,
and,
um,
and this is against the law.
So fortunately,
um,
Steve Lopez,
you know,
from the La Times who is a beast to me,
Steve,
don't put Steve on nothing cause he's gonna tell your Mama's maiden name,
the prostitute you were with,
you know,
the dog you left on the fridge of Steve,
don't play the radio,
he don't play,
you know.
So,
um,
he got ahold of it and I'm my councilman,
Herb Wesson,
you know,
I love him dearly now.
And um,
he saw it,
he said,
damn,
I guess you right.
And he credits me too,
has bringing this really to his attention.
Where before,
before it was like the guys breaking the law just deal with him like that,
you know.
So now it's,
it's,
it's the law and that's beautiful.
And he gave me a plaques,
Herb Weston,
you know,
actually gave me this food hero,
black full of food day,
um,
you know,
a couple of months ago.
That's amazing.
So essentially those two guys.
So Steve Lopez and who's the other gentleman?
Uh,
counseling and Herb Wesson,
Herb Weston.
So those two guys essentially were the,
the,
the force behind they saw what you were doing and they were the force behind
getting it didn't start out like that,
you know,
it didn't,
no.
Hell No.
They threw me under the bus before.
Not,
uh,
not,
Steve Lopez.
Not Steve,
not Steve,
but you know,
the city through,
let's just say the city threw me under the bus because they had,
they looked and realized that,
oh,
he did this before,
you know,
so I said,
no,
repeat offending exactly.
Is it again,
I wonder why he wasn't no damn humming birds and butterflies get his ass out of
here.
Flowers.
They wasn't having it.
So yeah,
so that,
but now they see,
and it's beautiful because now herb has actually,
uh,
he built a named in the area named after his wife.
So they sit in the,
and it was on a lot that's been vacant for years.
So it's,
so they're seeing it,
I don't know.
And they're supposed to address the fact that,
that I brought up that 26 square miles of vacant lots in the,
in La that and they said,
wow,
you're right.
You know,
we need to give up some of this space for people to grow gardens.
And it's just like you said,
what about if one lot on this block?
What about if every block had,
and that's where I,
that's where I'm at.
Joe.
Just imagine if you planted your parkways,
but just again,
it's like you creating a neighborhood,
you creating system,
you creating safety and you're creating health all in the same al at the same
time.
It's dangerous,
dude.
It's good,
but it's dangerous.
What's the danger for,
uh,
for the people that don't live on your block,
the people that setting the prices at the supermarkets,
you know,
cause your,
your visit to the supermarkets are now going to be less frequent.
Right?
But how much influence to the people that own the supermarket is actually have,
do you think they have a lot?
They have a lot of influence.
I mean,
you gotta think,
look,
it's not called big ag for,
for just for a reason.
You know,
we need,
we have to buy a shit.
You know,
they need somebody divided and guess what?
it's just like the dialysis centers.
I didn't see any dialysis centers driving in over here,
but you go to every hood you go to in the United States that I've been to,
there's a dialysis center there because people have diabetes cause and why and
why couldn't can't these dialysis center come in and say,
hey man,
if you change your diet for a week,
you might not need us.
Hell No.
We've created a whole nother medical industry that did not exist.
You fly over La and you look down at all those people that need food.
It's amazing how poorly it's planned out.
Yep.
When you think about all the lawns that are on these fucking golf courses that
use millions of gallons of water,
I mean,
I don't know if you've ever seen the statistics on when we are,
we're going through an insane drought right now for folks who don't know.
There was a recent story that said that we need 11 trillion gallons of water to
bring it up.
Just tobacco to where it's supposed to be.
Just to bring us back to baseline,
this is a place that I go to a,
it's to hone ranch is about,
uh,
an hour and a half north of here.
And they had this lake that was like one of the best bass fishing lakes in
southern California and all the bast died because the water level got so low.
There was no oxygen in the water,
the,
all the vegetation died and all the fish to start floating to service.
And the guy who works there was telling me like trophy bass,
like big,
you know,
seven,
10 pound bass just floating to the surface.
Wow.
And what,
what I see is this was,
this is not new Joe.
They knew this,
they knew that what kind of climate we have and all of a sudden we're at
critical mass and now all of a sudden if there,
oh,
uh,
yeah,
let's do something about the water.
No,
dude,
you should have did something about the water.
30 years ago.
You knew it was a problem.
You know where we live.
So why doesn't everybody,
aren't we collecting water off the roof of every damn house in this,
in,
in this city,
man,
it's,
they could address this,
all these millions and millions and trillions of gallons of water when it rains
or,
or just goals through the,
through the sewer system and none when you can collect that water.
It's true.
And my point was the amount
water that it takes to water this fucking golf courses is obscene.
Yeah.
I mean it's incredible,
but it's gotta be Green.
Come on dude.
Shit gotta be Green Joe.
Why are you playing?
Isn't that amazing though?
What do you think about the amount of money?
I mean,
obviously their money and it costs a lot of money to join country clubs and
shit,
but water is kind of a shared resource.
It's everybody's,
and if you looked out at la,
that giant mass of La and how few gardens or are,
how few areas are growing food,
it's,
it's really kind of crazy
when you look at what we pay for a bottle of water.
That's crazy.
When you use crazy,
we literally pay more for water.
Then we pay for gas and nobody bottled water and nobody's,
nobody's addressing the air of the girls.
Price is $3 Oh my God.
You know,
it was like,
dude,
you paying like $4 a gallon for water.
Do you don't realize that.
I was in Alaska and we were staying at this place on the Prince of Wales Island
and it's a way up high and it rains every day there and you could literally take
your glass and Dicky dip it into the water and drink.
It gets pure.
It's pure rain water.
And it's so funny because it felt so,
I'm like,
are you sure?
And they were drinking.
I'm like,
can you show you could just drink this water?
And then I thought about it,
I'm like,
how crazy is it that we're like,
we're scared to drink most water.
Like we're scared to drink fucking tap water.
A lot of people worried about tap water.
They have these Brita filters and charcoal filters and filtration systems in
their houses and shit.
But you know,
in the last guy,
you just dip your glass in there.
Yep.
Oh,
that's supposed to be because the water has been treated,
you know,
it has all kinds of shit and it has a fluoride,
it has all kinds of added stuff in the water to make it not harm us.
But everything,
I've read them fluoride,
it's not sexy.
Yeah.
Fluoride is not good for you.
Yeah,
it's not,
but it's in your water.
So
never did a series of studies on fluoride and Iq levels and it's,
yeah.
And I cue levels on children and the higher the level of fluoride was,
it corresponded with lower Iq rates.
And Joe's like a conspiracy.
Joe,
I don't know if it's a good thing or if I think there's a legitimate,
there's a legitimate belief that there's a conspiracy for maintaining fluoride
in water.
Well,
who the fuck doesn't have toothpaste?
it's,
it's a guy who worked at,
um,
I saw a story recently works at,
in Sacramento I think for the water treatment and hid heath.
He quit his job because of that.
And he's an advocate for take the flow right out of this water.
We need it.
You're ruining our kids.
You ruin.
And you know,
it's like the health problems.
Um,
but I,
it's too many.
That's what I'm saying to me,
you asked as a conspiracy.
It's too perfect dude.
There's too many people benefiting.
There's too many people benefiting from these kids and not being educated,
you know,
has the industrial prison industrial complex.
We got the,
the medical industrial complex,
the military industrial complex.
I mean,
we got too many complexes that in big ag that are benefiting man,
you know,
um,
and what we're paying for this food and where it comes from,
you know,
I,
I don't need,
I don't need my,
you know,
my tangerines to come from Cameroon or some damn place,
especially in La.
Yeah.
I'm here all year round.
Gross Shit.
All you need then as somebody you can't grow.
I got bananas growing on the street in front of my house and I had a doctor,
it's like,
you can't grow bananas in,
in La.
I'm like,
yeah,
Dude,
stop.
You know,
he's a doctor.
So I had to like,
yeah,
this is on the street,
dude.
You see that?
You know,
it's ironic.
One of the few things he can't grow in America.
It's cocaine,
right?
The climate wise,
it doesn't grow here.
It's like one of our big problems.
Oh,
is it a problem?
That'd be the opposite.
It's a problem that we have it here.
Like cocaine is a problem in the United States.
They can't even be grown here.
Is it still the problem?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's always going to be a problem.
Or you did you think that's by design?
I think definitely there's an issue with legalization because adults should be
able to do whatever the fuck they want.
I think you can go into cvs,
you can buy whiskey,
you know,
you could buy enough whiskey to drink yourself to death.
Literally.
Any,
any problem?
No,
no problem with her.
Or you can get a doctor to give you a prescription for a bottle of pills and
who's to stop you from just throwing the whole thing down your throat with that
whiskey and killing yourself.
No one can stop you if you're alone,
but yet they want to shield you from marijuana,
which has never killed anybody.
Mushrooms just never killed anybody.
All those things are schedule one drugs,
which are much more illegal than those pills or that alcohol,
which is ridiculous.
And that's clearly by design and in place clearly because there's a thing called
the,
um,
you know,
there's the,
ever see those commercials,
a partnership for drug free America.
They got millions of dollars from alcohol,
tobacco and pharmaceutical companies,
which is hilarious.
It's hilarious that drugs are spending money to keep other drugs that are less
harmful.
Illegal.
I did a joke about it.
I said this like hookers doing commercials against strippers.
It's,
it really is what stripper stripper is the gateway drug
and they are,
but that's a conspiracy for sure.
I mean they,
they actively conspired to keep marijuana and other drugs and aren't as
dangerous.
Hang is,
how did the drugs get here?
You know,
I mean,
come on,
it's,
it's too many.
It's too much.
The wait is way much for this drugs and just all of a sudden find a place where
they find them.
Man,
this is stop.
You know,
that that whole outlet,
that whole Ollie north,
you know.
Dang.
Yeah.
Freeway,
Rick Ross.
I haven't,
I've had him on the podcast couple of times.
I mean he told the story about how he brought the drugs in through the help of
the CIA.
I got you can't say anything.
No,
I can,
but I'll tell you later later.
I can't tell you.
Sorry.
Yeah.
But there's,
there's obviously there's a lot of issues with people trying to protect the
money that they make and it against the,
the greater good of mankind.
And that's what you believe is going on with the urban farming.
And the reason why this,
the,
these,
these cities are set up the way they are.
Well,
you see it.
I mean,
you,
you see it,
uh,
it's,
it's just like I said,
you go from one place to the next place,
to the next place.
Then it's like,
and you realize,
Oh shit,
this is by design.
It can't,
it just can't.
Why is this the same as it is in Euston?
Has It is in Philadelphia,
has it,
is in Louisiana,
you know,
it's coming on.
It's,
it's,
it's totally,
and there's like,
there's no money that the whole no money thing.
It's bullshit.
You know,
if there was no money there,
the corporations that are there,
the medical corporations that are there,
you know,
wouldn't be there.
And they have,
they're putting people on these drugs and you will take it
this for the rest of your fucking lives.
And there's a lot of money in those drugs.
Come on,
stop.
Yeah.
I tell people you don't need drugs.
You need a garden.
You know?
It's true.
And,
and a lot of ways it's true.
There's a myth that that's a thing about nutrition when it comes to doctors that
very few doctors have a long or prolonged education on nutrition.
They know very little.
I know it's shocking troop that you bring that up.
It's like,
like,
so Mike,
some I've talked to doctors.
Ah,
we had maybe a week.
Yeah.
Nutrition,
nutrition,
just what you put in your body to make you healthy.
And you've only had a few hours in class on that.
Well,
this is the way I try to tell people to look at it.
When they're skeptical.
The only thing that you take into your body to help your body recover and grow
is food.
That's it.
There's nothing else that goes in there that makes your body,
the devil ought to health except water.
The health of your body is directly related to the nutrients you take in.
If you have less nutrients like the reason why,
you know,
I mean your,
if your body doesn't have enough calcium,
we'll start pulling it out of your bones and you'll get osteoporosis.
This all,
all sorts of ailments.
Selenium,
a lack of selenium has been directly related to strokes.
There's all sorts of essential minerals,
trace minerals that you,
a lot of times people are not even getting from the food that they buy in stores
and all of these are necessary to have a complete healthy,
balanced body,
right?
And if you don't have those things,
your body starts going haywire and that's where diabetes comes in.
That's where all sorts of diseases come in.
All sorts of cancers are directly related to nutritional deficiencies.
There's all of that can be avoided at least to a certain extent by healthy food.
It is.
But I mean in that,
and then you ask,
is it by design?
Of course you got a kid in elementary school and they start from day one eat and
shit.
You know what I'm saying?
And then throughout their life they eat and shit.
Now you've compromised their bodies,
you compromise their brains and and in their DNA has changed because of this
food.
Food is as opposed to be alive,
you know,
and,
and when you grow it,
I think that's what I teach.
That's what I say.
If kids grow Kale,
they eat care because they see the connection.
They see,
I planted this little bitty ass scene and now I have this and I can eat it.
So there's a connection there.
There's a connection.
Soil is alive dude.
And people don't realize that.
People don't risk,
oh,
that's dirt.
No,
that's,
no,
that's dirt.
But this is soil and this shit is having sex 24 hours a day.
There's this shit happening in the soil.
It's the same thing with water.
We think Wa water is an organism that's alive,
but w we don't look at it like that and I always do.
A lot of times when I,
when I do talks,
I ask people say,
what's the most important thing to your life?
And um,
they'll like,
oh my,
my,
my husband,
my dog,
my,
you know,
my baby Mama.
And then no one ever says like joke.
What's the most important thing to your life?
The most important?
The most important out of everything.
Health.
No.
Air.
Air is the most important thing.
You're fucking,
if you're on food here,
food,
you should none.
Mr Mma,
you should know.
Okay,
somebody put your ass in a choke hold and you got all the blood because the
blood off your brain,
which that's what a choke hold does.
A lot of people think it's cutting the air off.
It's actually,
if you can't hold your breath for a long time,
if I choke you,
you're going out pretty quick.
You can only,
you get choked out in like two or three seconds.
It's pretty well,
some people can't go without air for for like 30 seconds to a minute.
Let me tell you something.
If someone's choking you for a minute,
like holding onto a choke,
you're fucking done.
You're done is a big difference.
Treat of holding your breath.
You can hold your breath for a minute.
No,
exactly.
But because people who done it for like 20 David Blaine do some crazy stunt,
they did it for like 15 skin divers,
deep dive free divers.
But I'm saying to people,
nobody thinks of air,
so we're not taught how to breathe ever.
You know,
unless you go to some yoga classes,
I mean,
you know them.
You realize.
So everybody takes Air Force for granted to me.
They never bring it up.
It's like damn without air.
And I think it's because you can't see it.
Right.
You know?
So it's not that important unless you're flying to Mexico City or,
or,
or China
or Singapore.
Right.
Did you see that shit?
I posted on Twitter.
Oh my God.
Take a look at this.
There was a thing that I posted on Twitter today where they're,
they're talking about,
I think it's Singapore,
was it Singapore,
Shanghai or some shit,
some place in an Asian country.
Beijing.
That's what it is.
That's fucked up.
And there they got to the point where everybody's walking around with gas masks
on.
Their city is toxic and they're forced to live there.
They're stuck.
And then somehow or another in this quest to make money and industry look at
these,
uh,
these images.
Watch as he scrolls down.
Look at this fucking town man.
But you can't see any,
you know,
you see like a hundred yards and that's it.
Those are not gas mass either though.
Oh Damn.
You got a baby with a gap.
A righteous gas masks on.
Yeah.
It's fucked.
And those kids are going to get super state.
Yeah.
So now they're using gas masks
cause the king,
they wanted a marathon with a gas mask off.
Look at that beautiful architecture and you have to,
and the heirs
that,
but you could only see like a hundred yards out.
Everything after that is just in the fog.
And that,
look at that.
That's insane.
Dude.
I flew into Mexico City recently and it tripped me the fuck out.
I've,
I flew into Mexico City and I took pictures and I put into my Twitter.
I'm like,
this is crazy.
You fly,
it looks like there's a fire.
Right.
You know how like when La sometimes like over the one on one,
they have those,
those fires that we will start making their way down.
And if you're anywhere near there,
it's like,
it's like you're in a cloud.
It's all just smoke.
That's what it looks like in Mexico City.
It's fucking crazy.
It's been scared to go to Mexico three.
I mean,
even the ruins they found underground where they built the city over these,
you know,
these ruins,
uh,
you know,
and I was,
I mean I had one point and had property over Mexico,
but it's,
I don't know,
Mexico City was just always scared the shit out of them.
Well,
it's really crazy as far as traffic,
but that's what it looks like when you fly in and crazy.
That took that shit from the plane.
That photo was just regular photo from the plane.
I took a few of them cause I couldn't believe it.
It's crazy.
It's like you see the amount of pollution,
like this is madness and there it is right there off of my Instagram.
And then on top of it,
what's really crazy is the gridlock.
It's,
you know,
sometimes in La there's some assholes that the lights turning yellow and they
still weasel their way into the intersection.
They block it off.
Everybody else in Mexico,
that's all they do.
That's all they do.
There's all gridlock all the time.
There's gridlock this way.
There's gridlock that way and the light turns green,
light turns red and nobody's going anywhere and they just kind of weaseling in
front of each other and everybody's trying to get ahead and no one gets
anywhere.
And you're like,
this is crazy.
Wow.
But then not honking at each other and they're super chill about it.
But it's normal for them.
It's so normal for them.
Who
wants that to be an arm?
I mean,
and I think that's what happens with with,
I think that's what happens with these kids.
And a lot of these neighborhoods,
it'd be,
it'd be that situation becomes normal.
I mean,
with me,
you know,
people were asking me,
why did I start growing food?
It took me a while because it becomes,
I have to do this to get this.
So what you do Joe,
that's what I do.
I do that.
But you don't realize how it's lunacy.
You don't realize why the fuck I need to do this,
you know,
why do I have to go out of my area to get healthy food?
You know,
when it's like,
Whoa,
it should be right here.
I shouldn't have to do this.
Got You started on this path.
Like how to do what it was,
the first thing that you planted.
I mean,
you know,
we've got,
we can go back to elementary school when we had the petri dishes,
when you put the seeds with the Brown paper towel and you watch them grow on the
side of the Petri dish and you plant them and you got beans.
I mean,
uh,
the thing here,
it wasn't nowhere being in the city.
And I,
you know,
I grew up in south central,
there was really nowhere to plant person.
We had stuff growing in the yard and the yard occasionally,
but it wasn't,
it wasn't something that,
you know,
that we was,
hey,
let's get in the garden.
What were,
what did it to me has an adult.
I remember going to the store and there was a tomato and it's,
you know,
and it's had a label on,
it says coated with Shellac,
you know,
to preserve and Alex your lack,
that's the shit.
We use them.
What shop for the,
you know,
for the wood when we,
set lack really,
dude,
they coat tomatoes with this tomato said coated with Shellac.
And I'm like,
damn,
when the last,
I ain't heard that word since the 70s,
you know,
and I'm like,
I'm cool.
And that kind of,
that was one of the things,
I mean,
I've always been,
um,
you know,
somewhat healthy.
I mean,
I had a brother that was,
uh,
used to have like Barrow 50 Gallon barrels of Spiralina plankton,
you know,
back in the day.
And so I was around it,
you know,
we used to go up the Antilles was one of the biggest health food stores here.
It used to be and um,
Pacific design center man.
And that was the place to go to pick up girls.
So uh,
you know,
to the health food store.
So um,
I've been in it but this,
that,
that's basically what did it.
I remember that tomato and I'm like this is not cool.
This is crazy.
This is a paper that was written on it.
[inaudible] Vera Base Gel surface coating for shelf life extension of tomatoes.
That is insane.
Sassy.
See don't you love the Internet?
Sometimes at the abstract shall lack whatever that means.
I'm an Aloe Vera Gel.
We used to develop an edible surface coatings for shelf life extension of tomato
fruits.
The coding was prepared by dissolving d waxed and bleach shall act in an
alkaline acquiesce medium as such,
as such as well as in combination with a g incorporation of agg and soul
[inaudible] coding improve permeability characteristics of the coding.
What the fuck is all of that?
That's so crazy.
That is fucking quick.
I mean,
I remember that like,
like it was just,
did they,
oh my God,
I never heard of that before.
And I was just like,
and then,
you know,
you
just wake up and you realize that all this stuff does not need to be in our
food.
You know,
the high fructose corn syrup,
the stuff and might have a thing.
You know,
I,
I do a thing with these kids sometimes when I,
when I taught at,
um,
at schools and uh,
I'll bring snacks and I said,
no,
but you can't eat them.
I said,
I want you to get on your phones,
get on your computers.
I want you to tell me what these ingredients are,
you know?
And they'll say,
oh,
this is is,
I'm such and such and it's related to hypertension and diabetes and Dada.
And they'll get another one.
Oh,
cancer doctor.
And somebody always comes up with this line that they can't read.
The word is so damn long that they can't five bus as a perfect you were,
you're the one I was waiting for.
It's real simple.
If you can't read that shit,
don't eat that shit.
Nothing,
nothing in nature that I know of that there's adequate has 16 letters.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's real simple,
man.
And you just go on a thing and you're like,
wow,
damn,
they straight trying to kill us.
You know what?
That's when you realize it's like you got,
they're putting poison in the food.
Why?
When you can have,
and then the stuff is cheaper then.
Then oil like potato chips,
oil,
potatoes and salt.
Okay,
but you have a potato chip that has this,
this category of stuff and it's less than an oil.
Why is that?
Don't they have to buy barrels of that bullshit?
Shouldn't it be more money instead of less money?
Well,
there's government subsidies,
which is where it gets really weird when it comes to corn that you know,
every corn farmer,
if they grew corn,
the way they're growing it right now without government subsidies,
they'd lose money and they'd stop growing corn.
They get money from the government to grow corn.
If you've never heard of this before,
you got to watch a fascinating documentary called king corn.
I urge everybody out here who's like never seen King Kong.
It's amazing.
It starts out with these guys.
They go and they get their,
their,
their body tested like their blood tests and,
and it turns out that like most of the carbon in their body comes from corn and
then they start carbon.
Yeah.
All the,
like literally like that the,
the building blocks of your body,
like the food that you take in.
And like I just tweeted something,
uh,
earlier today from my friend Lee camp who's a standup comedian,
is also,
uh,
an activist.
And one of the things that he tweeted today was about how two out of three
corners,
oh,
three out of four items in the grocery store contain corn.
Yep.
That's fucking crazy.
Genetically Modified corn.
Well that's also,
well,
almost all corn is genetically modified.
If you go back to the original corn,
it depends.
It depends on what you consider genetically modified.
Whether it's in a lab where they're splicing genes or whether it's just the way
they've,
you know,
they've changed all sorts of,
yeah.
Hybrids.
And they've changed all sorts of plants over the years to make them yield more.
And corn used to be like a scrubby little vegetables are very small and now it's
this big fucking healthy thing.
But the crazy thing is a lot of the corn that there's,
these people are growing.
You can't even eat it.
Yeah.
It tastes like shit.
Well,
a lot of it's for fuel now.
Yes.
For fuel or for feed for cows,
sick when cows are supposed to be eating grass,
you know,
bizarre.
I tell people,
I said,
you,
you're,
you know,
I started with soil.
I mean,
I started,
I made compost.
Compost to me is one of the most sexiest thing on the planet,
you know,
cause it's like,
that literally makes my nipples hard when I make compost.
And,
um,
and,
and I tell people,
so your plants eat soil,
they don't just grow in it.
That's where their nutrients come from.
So you need healthy soil.
So basically to meet you,
you know,
they tell us you are what you eat.
It's like,
no,
you are what you eat,
eats,
you know,
literally.
So with the cows,
they're supposed to be eating grass.
That's what,
that's what they're do.
But now we're feeding them corn,
we're feeding them all this other stuff.
And um,
can they,
are they digesting this the way you know that they were meant to digest?
No,
you're,
you're eating animals that have been fucked with.
Yeah.
That's why they're so fat.
The thing about the difference between wild game and like a cow that you buy
from a grocery store is that the cows have these layers of fat,
which makes it delicious when you cook them.
Cause it's all juicy and fat,
but easy,
easy.
But it's not really very good for you.
It's just all that extra fat.
It's just,
it's unnecessary.
And grass fed beef I think tastes better.
I mean I buy grass fed beef.
It's leaner buffalo.
Yeah,
it doesn't,
you know,
you,
it cooks quicker but it's a,
it's a better meat.
It tastes better.
You get used to that flavor.
But some people use that corn fed sick flavor of beef.
Well,
I think,
like I was saying with the kids,
with their DNA being compromised with this food,
now their taste buds are adjusted for this garbage,
you know?
So when you give them real food,
it's like,
that's nasty
moose.
You ever have moose?
That fucker over there?
I shot that one a couple of weeks ago.
I left.
Yeah.
Oh,
you don't even know Dan really liked that.
Yeah.
I had a treated,
yeah,
he cut all the meat off of it and then you boil the head,
there's a wire in the back.
You scramble the brains and pull it out the back.
Yeah,
that's it.
Worse.
Where do you get time for all this shit?
I find it right.
Find time I make it.
I don't really have time.
I somehow or another just do shit.
And then I have a bunch of people scrambling after me trying to get ahold of me,
but I'm out of cell phone range,
shoot animals.
But I,
my goal was by the end of 2014 to have all the meat in my house from wild game.
And I'm there because I have 400 pounds of Moose in my freezer.
Because of that most,
you'll never even seen moose on a menu.
Nowhere.
It's,
we can't get it commercially.
It's only available in the wild.
Like you literally cannot buy it commercially.
You can't,
he can't sell it.
You can't buy it.
In some countries they sell and by elk in America,
the only way you could buy El,
cause most of it comes from New Zealand where they allow it in New Zealand,
they grow these animals over there,
but there's no predators.
So New Zealand has like no regulations on hunting.
You could just go in there and like any,
you could go there right now and shoot a ton of elk,
shoot geese.
You could shoot anything the fuck you want.
You don't need tags.
And the reason being is they have an over abundance of these game animals.
I like very precious here.
Yeah.
Like in America or in Canada where I shot that these animals are regulated.
Like you can't just go and shoot them.
You have to have a tag and they limit the amount of tags that people get every
year.
So like if they,
they've,
they monitor the population from the air and the ground,
they don't want to make sure that they know pretty,
pretty close to exact how many animals are in the area and they,
that that way they issue tags and the tags being how many animals you're allowed
to do
kill.
How do you get it back to United States?
Well,
I had a guy drive that back for me from it,
from Canada.
So a long process if it wasn't for,
uh,
for him driving it back when had to ship it and it's really expensive,
but it's expensive to have someone drive it back to.
And then the one on the right,
that's a mule deer from Montana,
I shot that won a couple of years ago.
That was the first animal ever shot.
And that was like,
that was only about 90 pounds.
It was 180 pound animal,
maybe about 70,
70 to 90 pounds of actual meat.
Did you have to stock them?
Yeah.
Both of them.
You have to stalk them.
Yeah.
You got to sneak up on them.
You got to make sure you're in the right area of the wind.
Can't be blowing towards them.
You want to make the wind blown in your face so that they can't smell you.
That's the thing is smell you.
They don't know what the fuck you are saying.
If they had an ar 15 and yo ass side of that,
what would that make the Shit Lou?
Cause they antler thing.
They too far.
Listen,
I'm not always,
people always want to say talk about like things being even,
I'm not interested in even.
Okay.
I'm interested in eating at us.
This whole idea,
is it fair the pressure rifle does?
No,
it's not fair at all.
I'm a cheater.
I'm 100% cheating.
I shot a bear with a bow and Arrow too.
I'm going to meet and bear stu tonight.
Bear on the real real.
Yeah.
I'll show the pictures under real kind of bear.
Black bear.
Black bears are delicious.
What would that and in the valley that was in Canada,
in the valley,
that was in Canada.
That was in Canada.
Beer.
You shout a receipt receded,
fuck around.
You know he bears.
That's a gay dude in receipt.
That's the Moose right there.
Yeah,
that's the Moose I showed a couple of weeks ago.
But I'll show you the bear.
And you know a lot of people have these ideas about bears that are based on like
Yogi and Booboo,
right?
Let me,
let me explain to anybody who thinks that bears these cuddly,
cute animals.
First of all,
bears will fucking kill you 100% not only would they kill you,
one of the reasons why you have to kill bears like mature boars,
is to keep the bear population healthy because bears eat bears and one of the
things they do is the,
the male bears loved eat cubs stars.
The cubs can't get away.
They're all cannibals.
That's one of the most fucked up thing about bears is that they're almost 100%
cannibals.
So their DNA is,
it's kind of Funky,
but it's,
you know,
it's survival there.
It tastes like a pig fucked a deer.
That's what it tastes like.
It's like a combination between a pig and a deer.
How would you know that,
Joe?
That's my bear.
That's the bare of shot.
Wow.
Yeah.
Shut that with the you guys bear dude.
Well that's,
that's it's close to fair as it gets a bow and Arrow with a bear crossbow.
No regular content on bow.
I mean it's not really fair.
No,
it's not fair.
You get to do barrier camel flash shit and be in a tree and all that.
Just talking all that shit.
Actually,
we were on the ground,
but a problem with shooting in a tree is,
um,
you're shooting down and one of the things about a bear is you want to make sure
you go straight through both of the lungs to kill him like that,
that you shoot through both lungs.
They're dead in 30 seconds.
Within 30 seconds they're gone.
But when you shoot down,
sometimes if you're shooting at an angle,
you're going to get one lung.
They might survive.
They'd be like really badly wounded and get away.
So it's,
especially with a bow and Arrow,
it was very important that you're very accurate.
You've got to practice like a motherfucker.
I was practicing hours every day shooting 150 hours a day every day getting
ready for this hunt.
So,
and that was,
that's a rifle.
You shoot a moose with a rifle,
boom.
That soccer was down in seconds.
But I'm doing it for a couple reasons.
One for the meat,
because the meat is delicious and is the only way to get moose meat unless you
know somebody who should.
I wish I knew.
I should have brought some for you man.
And bear me.
I mean,
yeah,
that's crazy.
Yeah,
it's good.
Bear me is good.
We're just not exposed.
If you talk to people that live in Canada that live up there,
that hunt them on a regular basis or Alaska,
people that hunt them on a regular basis.
Like when we were in Canada,
when I was heading in Moose camp,
we ate a a bear roast.
We had a bear roast while we're up there.
It's good.
It tastes good.
It's an interesting,
neat.
So what do they would have bears eat?
No.
What do Lucy Moose,
those are herbivores,
you know,
so they're all eating grass and you know,
different leaves and they get that big.
They are,
I know our mess.
That was 900 pounds and that wasn't even a big one.
I mean,
you look at his antlers,
that's not even a big moose.
My Buddy,
my buddy Ben,
he shot one that was about 1400 pounds while we were there.
It was fucking huge.
That thing walked down into the road.
We were,
we were,
we were driving actually on the way to spot where we're going to hunt and this
fucker just walked out onto the road and we were like,
Holy Shit.
It was huge.
Just towering over the truck that we were in and he jumped out and he shouted at
like 240 yards from the road.
Yeah.
But my point is like,
that's the type of animals we're supposed to be eating.
I was feeling shitty the other day.
He killed Bambi.
He's Dad fucker.
That's not bammies dad.
Bambi is a cartoon.
Yeah.
Bombies if I didn't kill Bambi,
his dad,
he would have gotten his asshole eaten by
coyotes.
They would eat them.
Asshole first.
I'll show you videos.
That's how they do it.
They,
they attack the legs,
they pull the hamstrings apart to the deer can't get away and they start chewing
on the asshole.
I'm not kidding.
Maybe that's where all the flavor is.
It must be.
Yeah.
I don't think they have good tastes.
Right.
The point is if you don't do it,
it's not like they're going to live forever.
Like everybody has this idea that these animals are beautiful.
Are you going in there?
Kill him.
They're going to die,
flowed over us.
It's a fuck load of us to Joe and we're going to fucking die people.
Okay,
I'm here for me.
They're not there for you.
They don't give a fuck if they not fucking with you.
Do.
Oh,
but they would.
If you were wandering through the woods,
why wouldn't you be?
Why should they be allowed to want it to the woods and you can't,
oh my cause team people,
team people.
Ron.
Okay,
I'm not on team.
Bear bears.
Don't give a fuck about you.
Yeah,
Ben,
they're delicious with you in their territory.
What's mine and around this hippie mother fucker know they're turning around in
his mind.
You know why?
Because I'm a human.
Yeah.
It's,
if I have a tag and it's legal and the humans have deemed at the numbers need to
be dropped,
that's legal.
That's my territory.
If I'm out there with the right,
that's how you have to think.
If you want to bring back that meat or are you a vegetarian by no,
stretch it on.
There you go.
So what are you doing?
You getting food from a supermarket?
Hitman.
That's where you're doing weird.
No,
no.
My Shit is,
I get my shit from some guys that raise it.
The older guys personally.
So you have a relationship with farmers.
They grow grass fed meat.
No doubt.
So you'd all healthy stuff tried to,
yeah.
Yeah.
No,
that's the most healthy though.
That's the game I was telling you.
I wasn't feeling good.
And the other day I was feeling kind of rundown.
I cooked myself a moose steak and when you eat it,
you're like,
whoa.
So do you,
do you butchered the shit to photos?
I'll show you.
I got proof.
I saw this woman,
man,
she posted some pictures on Facebook where she laid out cable and they brought
up a deer or something in and right there on the table and they,
they chopped it up and made 'em deer steaks and shit.
Yeah,
that's how you do it.
Yeah.
It takes a long time,
but that's how you do it.
Okay.
And when you do the classes to duty Shit,
I got super lucky.
And then I learned from some hunters,
you know,
I learned from some real experience guys.
My friend Steve Rinella was the first one that takes me out hunting.
That's where I got that mule deer.
And he has a TV show that's on the outdoor network called meat eater.
And,
um,
what you do is,
you know,
you,
you essentially do what people have done for thousands of years.
She'd take the skin off and you cut it into meal size portions.
I mean,
that's what it's all about.
Do you guys use the skin?
Ah,
you can,
you know something.
You guys use the skin,
Joe?
No,
I didn't use this again.
I mean you can,
but I don't have any use for it really.
But if you leave it in the woods,
it gets eaten.
I mean it,
it's not like it goes to waste.
Animals eat it.
I mean,
there'll be rodents and all sorts of animals that eat it.
it's a part of the,
when you,
anything you leave behind,
it becomes a part of the ecosystem.
The idea that it goes to waste being composed.
Yeah,
it does.
We turn the compost,
everything.
That's why I said everything turns to compost.
Everything.
It doesn't even just turn the compost animals eat it.
Like if you leave behind the bones,
wolves will come and pick the bone.
The park,
coyotes will come.
You know,
th the cycle is,
is enormous.
I mean,
the cycle of life is enormous.
So like I would prefer if I could use every part of the animal,
like the bear.
I have the rug,
it's coming to me and the bear skin rug.
I'll use that in my house,
you know?
But,
um,
the,
if you leave stuff behind,
it's not going to waste.
Animals are going to eat it.
You know,
it's all a part of this.
The continuous cycle.
No dough.
My point being those animals are as healthy as you're ever going to get.
I mean they,
there's no antibiotics,
no human intervention whatsoever.
They are as close to nature as possible.
The problem is with 300 million Americans there,
there's not enough game animals for everybody.
Just be out.
But that doesn't stop you or me or anybody else who really wants to do it.
If you really want to put in the effort,
you can acquire your own meat.
I've seen these guys that that's how they,
like with the Buffalo,
they literally have a truck that they take,
right?
Like right there where they killed soon as they killed a buffalo.
It's [inaudible].
It's done.
And you're dealing with,
with a buffalo,
you're dealing with a 2000 plus pound animal that's more than a thousand pounds
of just meat.
It's incredible.
I mean,
and buffalo is delicious.
Yeah.
The problem with buffalo is very little.
Buffalo is wild.
Most of it is like there's,
there's some buffalo ranches in California actually we can go and hunt in quotes
a buffalo,
but you're hunting in a high fence operation where they have like a couple
thousand acres and these animals live this permanently inside these fences and
you just go seek them out and shoot him.
I mean,
it's more wild than a farm for sure,
but it's not like really wild in some cheat and shit.
May and may were hunting buffalo wild buffalo in Mexico.
That's that.
Yeah.
Those are real buffalo.
Those are buffalo that were actually introduced in the 1950s they brought like
30 buffalo down there and now they have a huge sustainable heard in Sonoma.
It's sustainable.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
there's a lot of them.
There's,
there's a large population of buffalo and Mexico,
like the United States has tags.
Like you have limits.
They'd tell you how many of you can kill and when you can,
and when the population is dropped,
they reduced the tags and then you have to enter into a draw.
You know,
that's how most it's done in most parts of the country.
Like there's places in the country where like elk especially very difficult to
get a tag and certain places you put in you might not get one for four or five
years.
So we are now,
they,
since the natural
predators,
what would have been,
are no longer there.
So we were taking their place.
Well,
there are definitely still natural predators almost everywhere where these,
these kind of large game animals,
there's mountain lions and wolves,
especially in Canada,
Canada,
they have so many wolves in Canada that where I was in DC,
they have no limit to the amount of wolves you can kill.
They want you to kill wolves.
We got coffee.
Oops.
Here at Hollywood they might like coyotes.
Jackals.
Hmm.
But the point being that I have a garden in my house,
um,
we have chickens,
my wife and I,
we have 24 chickens.
We get all our eggs from these chickens.
So we get fresh eggs.
You get blue and green eggs,
they're blue and green and Brown.
And they look different.
Man,
when you crack those eggs,
it's hard to cut dark orange yolk because it'd be glowing and it's so healthy
for you because my chickens are wandering,
we feed them,
we feed them some tables,
graphs like vegetables and we will actually feed them like some fish or some
leftover before or game meat or something like that.
But they also wander around the yard.
So they're constantly eating grass.
They're kind of like,
when you see vegetarian raise chickens.
Right.
Guess what?
You're not supposed to be there.
Fucking omnivores chickens are dinosaurs.
That's what they are.
Yeah.
They're dinosaurs that survived.
I mean that's really is what they are.
And they eat everything.
They,
they wander around the yard and they eat.
Like my wife will like lift up rocks and they text slugs.
They go fucking crazy for worms and slugs and bugs.
It's kind of cool to watch them do it.
I used to have a friend and I used to take my,
um,
those grubs.
Yeah.
I used to take the grips from the compost and give them to their chicken.
They go crazy.
Right?
Yeah.
Mine are cool because they're like,
we have so much interaction with them that they're like my friends.
Like I go see them,
I go,
hello girls and I opened up the gate and let them out into the yard and they,
you know they run through your legs and stuff.
They're so used to us.
We could pick them up but yet they make food for us.
You have a rooster or to no.
Yeah.
Why do you say it like that?
Cause that mother fucker will wake up your neighbors man,
I don't want,
I opened the gate once at the pupil had this rooster man,
the chickens are in there and the rooster,
I didn't even,
he was like six feet in the air clause.
Done like fuck you up.
I'm like,
I'm cool.
Testosterone motherfucker.
Chickens.
Testosterone is a terrible,
which is a hell of a dreaded,
it's the reason why the buildings are so tall and offenses are so high and the
guns are so strong.
It's all testosterone.
If it was only women on the planet,
they just be some fucking arguments.
A few hair pulling matches
or testosterone is what's up.
My friend Remi.
Um,
he,
uh,
he has chickens and his neighbor had a rooster that was coming over and fucking
his chickens and just going crazy.
And so he put a concrete,
like there's the,
that you apparently by these roosters that are like made out of cement.
They look like a rooster and he placed it in front of the chicken coop and this
rooster came over and started fighting with the concrete rooster and just got
his ass kicked.
Just I fell down and kicked it and stop coming around.
We need
you.
Right?
He's like,
that rooster,
fuck me up.
And he would try,
he just came over and picked it and kicked it and just said,
fuck this and just literally stop coming around
when you see what they do to these chickens though,
man.
It's terrible.
Yeah,
it's pretty bad.
It's pretty,
It's,
it's,
I didn't know that,
you know,
that they do these chickens like that and to see this chicken's feathers and
body raped up and scarred up.
It's like,
Damn Dude.
Is it that?
Yeah,
I'm cool on that.
Yeah.
When you bought chickens that have been factory farm too,
there's,
it's illegal in a lot of places to film the conditions,
right?
Like they've made laws against exposing how inhumane it is to raise chickens
like that,
which is what kind of a fucking law could you have that would,
that would prevent you from exposing something that most people think should be
illegal?
Like QMAP engine that,
no.
Well,
I mean,
we have,
we,
we need those chicken sandwiches at these fast food restaurants,
man.
You know,
it's crazy.
It's really cool,
neat and quick.
So,
I mean,
when you think of the numbers,
the,
uh,
you know,
I,
I remember like the guy that runs the food at La Unified,
he was like,
he telling me,
Ron,
I've already served 300 and some thousand meals.
This breakfast is this morning,
you know,
and you think,
God damn,
you know,
I've had substance something thousand hundred thousand chickens,
lunches,
and you're like,
and that's just,
you think that's just a school?
You know?
What about everybody else?
Right?
So,
yeah.
So yeah,
it's,
I don't know how are we going to do that?
But I think it's a numbers issue,
right?
Yeah,
it is.
But you know,
we have this,
we can't feed everybody.
We don't have enough food to feed.
Everybody know you guys waste.
They said it's up to 50% of the food now that's to produce.
They say it's 50% of the food is going back to waste,
man.
So I,
my whole thing is like I don't need you to feed me dude.
You know,
and I guess you are on the same tip.
It's like no,
I got got my bow and Arrow and I got my ar and I'm cool.
You know,
I feed my and I got my chickens.
Yeah,
yeah.
If you could feed yourself,
it would be ideal.
The problem is a lot of people that live in apartment,
they don't have a lot of them.
They don't have the land.
They have the space.
And that's where like your idea of using the medians and using empty lots like
God,
there's got to be enough room on every block and it should be mandated.
I mean if we have,
look,
if you look at La,
you look at the grid of La,
if,
if it's set up the way it's set up and,
and doesn't,
it should be engineered to have these spaces in it.
And if it was engineered
to have these spaces,
one on every block,
it wouldn't look much different than the way it looks now.
But it would supply food to everybody that lives on those blocks.
Yeah,
I mean it,
it's,
it's perfect.
I don't know why they said that's what I'm saying and that's why they have to
know this.
Do you think it,
but who are they when you say they have to know this or you think that they're
taking advantage of the situation as it exists now?
Or do you think they actively engineered?
Because this situation has been there for a long fucking time now.
So people that are in power right now or they've essentially,
they've stepped into power after the,
the,
it was already in place.
Yeah.
But if everybody started growing in food,
think of this,
the system that you attack and eliminate [inaudible] they,
they have these things called lobbyists and everything.
Man,
they're going to be up in an uproar.
Man.
That's a real problem,
right?
Yes.
Are fucking creepy.
They're creeper.
I really are.
I mean that,
that situation is very strange that someone came up with that shit though.
I don't know.
Demon spawn.
It's this fuck.
There's a lot of things,
special interest groups.
The fact that the supreme court made it so corporations can donate money like an
individual as much as they want,
which is just fucked.
And then you have people that are paid to say that this should is healthy and
yes,
and that's what's crazy.
And it's like,
how do you sleep?
You know,
like the,
these companies that have,
I'm like,
do you guys eat this shit that you produce or have had?
Do you have,
you drank the Koolaid and uh,
I don't fucking Doctor Oz was on TV talking about Miracle Diet pills or miracle
cures for.
Yeah.
And Dr and Dr [inaudible] is my dog too,
man.
Yeah.
He my mind.
He's cool.
You know what I mean?
It's cool peeps,
but I don't know what the hell that was about.
I mean the same thing with
exactly what I was about
talking to her.
I was just thinking about that.
Numerous has five 50
24th nobody drives a 24 potholes.
They destroy your wheels.
Everybody gave up on Rems,
right?
Remember what spinners?
Spinners was a tipping point.
It's like people had nice rims and then the spinners and everybody went,
yeah,
let's shut this shit down.
It's time to shut this shit down.
And then we had to bring a pack and now everybody has stock rims.
You know,
Doctor Oz is not interested in no 24 standard,
19 inch wheels are fine.
He just wants to just drive around and just listen to music and nice Mercedes.
Thinking about those diet pills,
making them all that money.
Well,
I mean,
what's his name?
What was,
what was Dr Phil had a problem some years back,
you know with what?
But the same kind of product kind of thing.
Endorsing that Shit.
Chris bitches,
but we never get in trouble.
Oprah should be president,
man.
I'm telling you though.
Everybody wants a woman president.
Why Not Oprah?
No,
I think,
I think Michelle should be President
Obama's yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Why is that?
Why do you think?
I don't know.
She just,
she's sexy and she's just seemed like,
she just seemed like a beast man.
She just seemed like she,
she know what time it is.
I Dunno.
Well,
it wouldn't be a bad thing for a woman to be president because I think women are
much less,
wait,
whoa.
Back Up.
But the first person,
they ha they were trying to get in there.
Elizabeth Warren or Mission Hillary Clinton?
No.
The chick that can see,
can see,
you can see Russia from her front porch,
you know,
or some shit.
That was just a ploy to get scared white people to vote for carrying her.
That's all that was.
That was like,
but they loved her.
They loved her concept of her,
but once it was exposed,
which she really is,
then they didn't like her.
That's why it didn't work.
They found out she's a fucking moron.
When Katie Couric was interviewing her like,
oh my God,
what magazines do you read?
What newspapers do you read?
It's like a vicious and read.
She doesn't read shit so wrong emails.
It's true.
She's a fucking on that interview.
It was like,
you realize and they lampoon the shit outta her on Saturday night.
My Dad.
Yeah.
It was bad though.
While it was great.
I mean that's what made a,
what's her name?
What's the funny woman that did her on Saturday night live that made her famous?
That's what made her famous essentially.
Well then then that Lisa Ann porn star dinner and those,
uh,
that made her famous to those porn videos when she played Sarah Palin.
Don't pretend you don't know.
No,
I look at him.
He slept buyer.
Who does this?
Porn porn.
No,
I'm not saying,
I'm not just saying,
I'm just saying that I haven't done in dove in porn every day,
but,
but no,
I'm at least saying no,
I don't see,
I'm not like you do it.
I don't get invited to the conferences and all that shit.
Yeah,
whatever.
I don't,
I don't go to anything.
This is what I,
I go to,
I go to a UFC fights and I shoot.
How many stores?
Daddy?
Oh,
Bambi.
Bambi and Yogi and blue.
Blue and gold.
That's right there.
I shot him right in the Dick.
I'm going to eat a bowl or burger later tonight.
Yeah,
no,
you got to put me up on that.
I mean,
I tasted good too.
I wish I brought him in for you.
You eat snake.
I have eaten snake.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's very lean,
you know,
but it's very good for you.
You know what's really,
really good for is alligator.
I,
I've only had it like a restaurant where it was like frozen and thawed out and
it wasn't that good.
But apparently according to the people that like actually hunt alligators,
they do the protein analysis on the meat.
It's like twice as much protein,
beef.
I mean,
it's something you can get it in.
Um,
you can get it in Louisiana where they have so many alligators now.
Those stupid alligator shows those swamp people and it's fucking redneck
hillbillies wandering around shooting these alligators.
They shoot 500 of them a season.
They're allowed to shoot
500 alligators a season.
That's how many there are.
I mean,
they're infested.
So what does the season though is that I know here is that it's usually a come
on,
you said a couple of months?
Well,
it depends on the animal.
I've head gate,
I've had a,
I think I've had a gate or,
um,
uh,
was it poor boy or something real?
Yeah.
Wow.
No,
I mean Louisiana,
I'd be big as a house if I lived there.
The food deep fried the fuck out of everything.
I'm just saying the food is,
it's flavor dude.
You can't find that flavor nowhere else.
And that shit is just like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
I don't,
I go and it's like,
Damn Dude,
you know,
I try not to eat like two weeks before.
I know I'm going to Louisiana because I know I'm just going to fuck
you.
Like spicy food.
I love that show,
man.
Come on man.
Good Cajun restaurant in La.
Uh,
not like Louisiana.
I haven't found nothing.
That's,
that's like Louisiana,
that Real Gumbo.
I mean,
even when you go to house of Blues and in Louisiana,
it's a whole nother game.
And I,
and I remember seeing Dan Aykroyd once here and at the House of Blues in
Hollywood,
you know,
and I just,
I mean,
I was in Louisiana and I think Ada House of Blues Shit three times,
you know,
so I'm like,
damn,
that's good.
The food was the bomb.
And I'm,
I told,
you know,
accurate say man,
this,
this food man,
y'all need the same food that he didn't take it too good.
I said,
y'all need to,
y'all need the same food that they got it and knew that you're the chef you got
in Louisiana,
man.
He say he didn't take it to grin on his face,
kind of a change.
So look man,
you know,
I thought it was putting them up on,
I thought I was putting them up on game.
He's a squirrely dude.
Yeah.
You ever hear them talking about Ufo shows?
No.
Oh,
he's hilarious.
He's fucking believes every damn story of Ufo was ever he.
Yeah.
He does all these UFO documentaries.
He's always the narrator for these UFO things.
Apparently he's just on Ufo nut.
Okay,
so what do you think about chem trails?
What do I think about chem trails?
Yes.
This is the reason,
and this I did a special on a shot,
an episode of this for the Scifi show.
The I did.
When you see those clouds across the sky,
when a jet is going across the sky,
that is absolutely 100% a jet engine reacting to the condensation in the
atmosphere.
When a jet engine is driving or flying through condensation,
the way it spins and the heat temperature,
the changing of the temperature of the air causes artificial clouds and this is
scientifically documented.
No one in the scientific world disagrees with it.
However,
when you talk about has the government sprayed things from the sky 100% they
definitely have.
Not only have they done it,
it's documented.
These tests have been documented.
They did one in,
was it Detroit?
I think it was Detroit where they,
they wanted to test during the Cold War.
What would happen if the United States got a face sprayed?
Some sort of a biological age and like a biological weapon.
So they sprayed this,
these particles into the sky.
Which Detroit?
Yeah.
When we,
who we don't need Detroit.
Let's just test these.
They said that these were innocuous particles and they wanted to measure them
and they definitely for sure have experimented with cloud seeding.
They know how to start rain and rain.
That's what happened in Vietnam.
Oh yeah.
They did a lot of shit in Vietnam.
They did a lot of experimenting in Vietnam.
Well,
it's one of the things they do whenever they go to war.
Whenever they go to war,
they bust out.
Also look at the fucking depleted uranium shells they denied using and the
original Iraq war that caused all these veterans to get sick as fuck.
All that Gulf War syndrome.
Most scientists believe that it's directly from depleted uranium for sure.
They used and they denied it for the longest fucking time,
but they use these depleted uranium shells.
Apparently they just blow through everything tanks and armored w weapon
carriers.
They just boom,
depleted uranium is so insanely dense.
It just goes through everything and that's it's fucking nuclear waste,
you know.
So they're creating these weapons out of nuclear waste.
The shit has a half life of like a 100,000 years.
So these soldiers are around these burnt out husks of these,
uh,
these tanks that they shot with the shit that breathing it in and they all get
deathly deathly ill and that,
that's a fact.
And that's something where they get away with experimenting with things like,
look,
we're already killing a million fucking people.
Let's experiment with some shit.
So that's what they do.
And then that shit still in the air though.
Yes.
But as far as like what people think chem trails or like you see those clouds
across the sky and every like,
oh,
the government spraying us.
No,
that is not what happens.
And when you say that it,
it,
the real problem is it throws everything else into question because it's so
easily disproved.
It makes it look like people are being kooks and then it makes it,
it makes everybody like,
like,
oh,
the fucking sky is falling.
I,
no,
no.
It's a fucking artificial cloud created by a jet engine.
It's that simple.
Ready in grids though,
because flight patterns are in grids.
It's real simple.
When you see planes flying from Burbank to Phoenix or you're going the same
route every time and they crisscross each other.
Everybody's looking for some crazy grand conspiracy when it comes to these chem
trails,
but it is 100% jet engines interacting with condensation.
We talk to scientists,
we talked to people that believe in people that don't believe,
people that believe in conspiracies and believe in chem trails at their fucking
loony there.
Lily,
any man,
they didn't do the work and when you talk to them about w the,
the actual fact like you show them like a real jet engine that is interacting
with the condensation,
the atmosphere and creating these artificial clouds.
All of a sudden they don't want to believe that those are the government made
that video.
Not another fucking southwest,
not it to fucking flight.
It's a flight flying out of Burbank.
They're not spraying Matt.
Oh the aluminum and Barium.
We did this.
We have this interview with this guy who was talking about aluminum and Barium
in the soil,
and that's the aluminum embarrassments proven.
We did sample tests of this water and it had aluminum and Barium in it.
But I,
I talked to the guy said,
well,
it says sludge here in this,
in this exam says sludge.
I go,
what a sludge mean.
And he goes,
well,
I don't know.
You tell me what it means.
I go,
okay,
let's Google it.
So I googled sludges water mixed with dirt.
I go,
see you have dirt and water.
do you know that dirt is like,
has a big percentage of dirt,
is fucking aluminum.
Like aluminum is in dirt everywhere.
It's a natural,
it's a natural metal.
It's all over the fucking world.
There's aluminum.
It's like one of the most common metals.
So what you're saying is your dirt tested positive for being dirt.
And that's not evidence of a fucking conspiracy.
Not only that,
you know how ridiculous it would be to try over.
They're trying to control the population.
They're fucking controlling themselves to their spraying entire cities.
You'll stupid.
That is the idea that they're spraying cities.
Great.
And,
but my whole thing is when we look at the food,
what's the difference?
What are these people?
What is making this bullshit food?
What are they eating?
Joe,
here's a real chem trail.
You want him a real chem trails that burning gasoline in the sky.
That's the real chem trail.
The real chem trails.
The thing that people aren't even worried about,
the thing that everyone knows,
everyone knows you get into a jet,
you fly to New York,
that fucking Chet is burning in the sky 30,000 feet above your head.
That's not innocuous,
right?
That shit is bad for you.
Or people around airplanes,
airports,
there's a high level of the asthma,
lung disorders,
diseases,
they're breathing in burning fumes.
That's real as fuck.
Well,
I mean it's like this,
that apartment that burned down next to the freeway and downtown.
So it was so funny that it would happen because a friend was talking,
you know how they have,
if you lived here,
you'd be home.
Now you know how they have those banners and,
and she was like,
what about if there was a banner we put on the building and said,
if you lived here,
you'd have cancer,
asthma,
you know,
and all kinds of shit is know what they already know that you don't do not build
buildings that close to it.
The fucking freeway.
And you've got these people's balcony literally 50 feet away from the freeway.
I don't know.
It's crazy.
By the way,
is not just a fumes.
It's fucking break dust.
Yeah.
People don't think about that brake dust when you will.
You clean your wheels.
If you take your car to a car wash and he tried to clean your wheels,
all that shit that,
that black powder,
that fucking shits in the air,
man,
that shit's in the air and it gets in your lungs.
And people that live in cities,
like in New York City,
they're sucking in brake dust all day long,
all day long.
You know,
if we really cared about people,
we would,
first of all,
we would change it.
We would make a carbon ceramic breaks.
It'd be mandatory because it limits the amount of brake dust.
They're more expensive,
but you can get them on performance cars,
but it limits the amount of brake dust drastically.
Like if you have carbon
ceramic breaks in your car,
you don't get brake dust or anywhere else.
It's different.
And they could choose,
they could come up with some sort of a material that's not so fucking toxic.
That's shit that you're breathing in.
You're breathing in a combination of the chemicals that are being burned in the
androgens gas,
the pollutants.
It was a lot of shit.
The,
and they,
what kills me is they,
they've done these tests and they said it should be at least 200 yard,
some crazy 200 yards away.
That's almost a safe zone.
And it keep building these living,
these buildings where people live in right next to these freeways.
Even school's right next to freeways like that.
And it's like,
no,
it's no concern.
You know,
it's just convenient and people are willing to live there and they just bury
their head in the ground like an ostrich,
you know?
Yeah.
There's a lot of that.
Well,
the reality is what we've constructed as far as like modern urban cities,
they're not natural or not natural,
and they're not well thought out in,
in that it's not healthy for your body.
Nope.
It's not an optimal,
they say that people that live in cities that will die an average of 10 years
earlier because of the fact that you're taking in these pollutants and toxins
and someone who lives in the country that falls exact same sort of diet in
lifestyle.
Wow.
Yeah.
No,
I mean that's,
we in,
instead of making homes for us to live in,
you know,
that,
uh,
accommodate us.
I think it's like you said,
it's just the opposite.
These houses are not made for us.
They're made for this space that when they're not,
I mean,
even when you think of the,
um,
you,
if you take the sun and the moon into account when you're building,
which was a lot of these things,
oh,
this is the property I'm building.
What's fits in here?
They don't take a lot of the,
the natural resources resources in,
into account when they're,
when they're,
when they're doing these construction projects.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
And then they're not worried about the effect of,
it's going to have on these people that live right next to the city or right
next to the freeway.
Rather,
they just know,
look,
we have this lot and we can make x amount of money if we put a hundred apartment
buildings in this lot,
fuck it,
let's build.
And they just build.
It's dark,
man.
It's just,
it really is this weird.
It was weird.
The people are willing to,
we got to find some light,
man,
you know,
this and that.
And that's kind of why I started,
you know,
what I'm doing.
I mean there's,
this is one thing,
but what you're doing with growing plants is you're actually filtering the air.
No doubt.
That's one of the reasons,
well,
when,
you know what I love about the fight,
you're filtering the air.
Um,
and the conversations that I have that I would never have had if this garden
wasn't there.
I mean,
people that I have,
you know,
homeless guys is man,
I love walking by here.
I walked by here every day and it makes me feel good,
you know,
and,
or the interaction with these kids that are,
have a guy that comes by every day to point him,
his kids in a wagon,
he points out everything and tells her what it is in Spanish,
you know,
so I a busload of kids from Harvard,
come wow.
And it's like,
and to me it's like,
wow,
really this is,
but one thing is like you said,
you're changing the ecosystem.
I get up every morning and I get to see hummingbirds,
I get to see butterflies.
I get to see the beads that took over a Trashcan,
you know,
for two and a half,
three years now,
you know,
I gave him a new condo recently,
with a window in the back.
But do you raise bees or they just lived the day they came.
And now I mean,
I'm kind of forced to deal with them.
Um,
yeah,
but I'm,
I'm cool with them because what's beautiful is all they have to do is fly 25,
30 feet to get,
you know,
and they're back to their hive.
So they get the sunflowers that I have planted on the front and um,
they're doing their pollination thing.
So it,
it's a win win.
I mean,
and that's the thing is that that whole,
if you build it,
they will come.
So I have pollinators,
I get to see butterflies,
I get to see,
but also get these damn baby bears that they call raccoons.
And you know,
they're crazy.
I think.
Stop Dude,
this scary.
No,
it says hell and they don't,
they don't run.
No.
You know,
they don't run.
And it's like you ripping up my garden,
dude.
And you just turn around and look at me and say,
you see these claws dude,
I will fuck you up.
Yeah.
They don't give a fuck about people know man,
those urban Ratko knowing their big dude,
they're kind of the kind of scary,
well they know how to open up trash cans.
Yeah.
First of all.
And they're getting a lot of food.
Yeah,
I heard that's all special one on PBS or something where in Japan they had
people had them cause there was this little cartoon and they were all,
oh so all the kids,
all of a sudden everybody had raccoons until they grew bigger and they start
tearing up the house and then what they did,
they just put them out of the house and now they're ruining like all this
ancient this way you architecture in um,
in Japan.
I mean just tearing shit up.
Yeah.
Raccoons.
Are there.
Interesting animals.
Cause they kind of have like little hands,
like a person because that's how they opened to get the trashcan in broad
daylight,
man.
They'll just turn over trash cans and,
but I have raccoons.
And then I mean one day,
literally I'm going,
I'm leaving going,
I was like nine,
10 o'clock.
And I walked out and I see this possum,
you know,
on one side.
And I'm like,
Damn.
And they see this possums are scary as hell to me.
That just dead.
They just,
and then he disappears.
And then I hear of shirt rustle in the tree and then there's this raccoon,
it's underground.
It's like trying to go into my flower beds.
I'm like,
what the hell is this?
What it was?
Is this Alison Wonderland with the cook just menagerie and shit.
You know,
I'm cool man.
But I can't,
I mean I,
I,
I love the interaction,
you know,
I love the people who,
the conversations I love,
you know,
cause I keep plants growing and I give people like if they like something,
I'm like,
here,
I keep seeing Linds man here grow your own.
You went to something like,
like my sunflowers here,
take it,
throw you off.
Would you ever want to live in a place that's like more,
um,
more of like
a outdoor environment,
like you know,
more of a rural environment.
What do you like the fact that all this is happening in there
in the city?
Um,
yes and no.
I mean,
and I think that's why a lot of people have,
you know,
they have the stuff and in parts of the valley in Malibu and places like that
where you can kind of have that kind of thing.
I mean,
uh,
where they have these big ass properties where you,
you do that and you have to come down the hill,
you know,
to um,
to go to the property,
um,
grocery store or something.
Yeah,
exactly.
I don't know.
I mean I like,
I like the city,
you know,
but also,
I mean I used to camp and stuff,
so I mean I appreciate that.
I appreciate the fact like you brought me back when you talked about the water
because you know,
the whole thing we learned is the snow runs down and then it hits all those
rocks and all that rockets.
The rocks are filtering the water and that water's just crystal fresh.
And it's clear because it's been filtered and filtered and filtered and filtered
by nature.
You know,
my whole thing is all this waste and all this fucked up shit is because of us.
We all are.
Waste is US mother nature don't waste nothing.
We do.
And what's really crazy is human beings.
If we had been around in this form for whatever,
a hundred thousand years,
the world's been around for four or something billion years,
but we've only been fucking it up for like a hundred right?
That's kind of crazy.
I mean,
since the industrial era,
so what,
150 years,
whatever it is,
that's nuts.
And in that time we fucked dad.
We've talked to like Japanese people that uh,
are in the Sushi and like,
oh my God.
And that that used to,
they used to be able to pull like just so many tuna out of the ocean and now
it's hard.
It's not the same anymore.
The numbers of depleted drastically.
I mean,
in our lifetime,
these whales that are,
are,
are being beached.
And then people wonder why they,
they see the open,
they open these wells and it's like tons of plastic inside of them.
Yeah.
There's that kind of a lot of birds that accidentally feed there.
They're young chicks,
they feed them plastic.
They don't know what a plastic is.
They think it might be a fish or something and they're trying to feed it to
their chicks and they,
they find these dead chicks on some of these islands draws Dominique's filled
with plastic and these mat,
these a cigarette lighters didn't never ever,
ever deteriorate.
No nothing.
It was
like we,
I mean and,
and it's like I asked some,
it's like the same thing with something as simple as leaves.
We throw,
it's a nuisance stuff.
We throw it away.
They,
we don't see that has,
has a resource.
Those are,
that's soil dude.
That's rich as soil.
If he brought it,
and I tell people,
I said,
who gardens?
Who Gardens in in the forest?
No damn body.
So how the hell did we have 350 50 foot trees,
Mother Nature Blade,
the game plan down.
And we just keep trying to change the,
no,
go back to nature.
Go back to the real shit long.
Why don't we,
why don't we emulate,
why don't copy what she's doing?
Have you ever gone to the rain forest and the Pacific northwest?
No.
It's amazing up there because the ground is really,
really soft.
Like when you step on it,
it's like smooshes under your feet because it's literally six,
seven feet of leaders that have just dropped down there and that the lower you
go,
the it becomes dirt.
And as it decomposes,
like the lower you get,
it's feeding the soil.
It's Kinda,
it's kinda making this own concourse is making his own soil and nutrients
though.
I mean then when you think of that whole process,
it's like a circle when you think,
okay,
this the,
the,
the tree knows it's,
it's winter.
So it's going to shed its leaves and those leaves create a mode for the tree.
So when it rains,
the water stays there and then those leads turn into soil.
I mean,
it's that simple,
but it's also one of the most complex things on the planet.
Take table scraps and like eggshells and all these different things.
We throw them away and they just go into a garbage somewhere.
But if we took those and put them in a compost pile and then added leaves and
all that stuff,
it's incredible nutrition for those plants.
Well,
my whole thing is I tell people,
to me it's compost made me realize that nothing ever dies ever.
Okay.
Because if this leaf that you hear this crunchy sound,
cause it's dried out,
that crunches energy,
but you put it with a Greenlee and all of a sudden,
so how does this shit heat up to 150 degrees?
If it was dead,
wait,
where did this heat come from?
If this is dead?
That's the weird thing,
right?
That he,
when you,
when you take a picture
fork and do a big compost pile,
you lift it up.
You see steam.
No,
I,
I just recently I had some meat and I had my,
I have some compost,
um,
bands that I just had made and I put some meat in the middle of the compost Bin
and this Shit Cook,
Dude.
I mean,
I,
when I flipped it over,
this stuff was like,
you hit,
put it in a dam,
you know,
skillet or something.
That's how I DePaul's could,
and it was crazy.
It is.
While they mean this heat,
I mean,
and I think that's what it took me too.
It's like damn,
I wonder if the survivalist in the F that get in the forest,
I wonder if this is a technique they use to keep the keep warm,
you know,
is to do a leaf pile or some shit like that.
Cause I mean,
you think of the heat that comes off of a compost pile.
Um,
will Allen,
who has growing power and what he does,
he heats his greenhouses with compost.
He builds the compost on the side of these.
He has these giant hoophouses and that's how he heats him is with compost.
And where does she say these greenhouses up?
Although he has,
um,
in,
he's in the Midwest and um,
she,
she's looking at my willpower.
He's,
um,
he's a bad ass.
Um,
he's,
um,
got kids training them how to grow food sheet.
He has like this closed loop system where he does the fish,
the fish and that fish,
the water from the fish goes into his double,
double tiered.
Um,
greenhouses are plants.
And so they watered the plants and then you eat the fish and he sells Easter
fest.
So He's,
yeah,
my friend Jason just started doing that in his basement.
He said it's incredible.
Like he spent months setting it up,
but the,
the water and the poop from the fish oil's down.
Yeah.
It filters down into the soil,
grows the plants from it and it's amazing.
Then he eats the plants.
Exactly.
And these systems,
these closed systems,
I mean,
you can have one of those in your fucking basement and provide yourself with a
lot of food.
Hydroponically.
A lot of,
a lot of this,
a lot of stuff has grown.
A hydroponic aquaponics and hydroponics.
Yes.
Um,
and I mean,
I think that's the way,
I don't know.
I haven't been convinced on the flavor come compared to soil yet on the high on,
have you tried it?
Yeah,
I mean,
but now I want to do a serious,
like get down.
Okay.
I got four different six different vegetables from the ground or six different
vegetables.
The same thing from hydroponic.
I mean a couple lives I have done cause I had one of those towers to,
someone gave me and I wasn't really convinced that the flavor,
I think that something about that soil,
do you know the best way to do it?
You know?
I mean I ain't saying it's the best but yeah.
Hell yes.
But at least with the aqua
panic is edible and his solution.
It's a solution.
It's a way to do it and it's better for sure than relying on supermarkets.
Totally.
The more you can be self reliant,
you know,
but and that's where the day and that's where the defiance comes in and that's
where that's,
that's where,
that's what a gangster come into me,
you know?
That's why I changed that.
That's why it was why you use gangster.
I said because growing your own food is gangster.
How's it?
How's IT Gangsta?
Because you're,
you're being self reliant,
you're taking care of yourself,
you're being a fucking bad.
Are you stepping away from the system anytime?
To me,
you step away from the system,
that Shit's gangster.
You know what I'm saying?
And in my whole thing is,
you know,
we got these old Hollywood rappers and shit does doing this thing where you
know,
they're,
they're rapping about all this violence and all the shit they do and they live
in behind gates in Calabasas someday,
you know,
and they still,
they still selling this bullshit on the streets.
So what did we have?
We have these kids emulating that shit that he made it look with and they,
you know,
so my thing was to give these kids something else to know the soil was gangster
dude,
you know,
let this,
let this shovel be your weapon,
you know,
not some gun I not singing about gang banging and Crippen and yo acids driving
around in a Bentley stop and not,
and they'll have no connection,
you know,
to that.
So my whole thing,
stop it,
stop,
stop pimping these kids like that,
that,
that is the term to pimping these kids because they're capitalizing on this.
There's this need to make something out of a terrible situation with that.
So they,
they take pride in that terrible situation.
Take pride and the violence and the gang bang,
the crime,
all that bullshit that really if they've escaped from it,
they should be trying to figure out a way to help people escape from it.
But instead of doing that,
they're pimping them.
Exactly.
In a lot of them,
I mean some of them have done it,
but a lot of them,
a lot of them haven't done it right.
You know,
and then,
and they singing about it.
So my whole thing,
I wanted to give these kids something else to look at,
man,
someone else till two to possibly grow into something else that where they can
design their own life rather than this life that's been designed for them
now.
What was it like when you did that Ted special and the one that I got ahold of
and I was like,
all right mom,
families on this,
because I had been talking about the idea of that for a while and I had never
seen anybody that was like really promoting it until you,
which is kind of crazy if you really think about the fact that people have been
growing things since people.
Why?
That's how you,
that's how you colonize places.
hey shit,
this soil's good.
Let's put the,
let's pitch the tent right here.
That's how people set up shit.
But for some reason,
until you came along and did a ted talk,
there weren't a lot of people that were doing this in an urban way,
especially not people that were being publicized.
I think,
yeah,
I think that's what it was.
I mean that's,
it was,
they were out there and me,
I'm a fashion design to dude.
I wasn't,
you know,
is that what you do?
You make cloud was supposed to,
that's what I did and to shit what,
oh eight when this recession,
this depression that they keep telling us it's a recession happen,
you know,
and it just,
it just hit it put me in a choke hold dude.
You know,
phone stopped ringing and people like we'd gladly pay you Tuesday for a
hamburger today and shit.
You know,
so it just,
it just fucked me up,
you know.
So this,
I,
I had other stuff that I did,
you know,
did some personal training.
I did this just to keep alive,
should you know,
caching bottles in and shit.
And um,
I was start growing more and my food,
you know,
and I start giving the food away and the reason,
that's why I haven't on the street,
Ted,
find out about you.
Wow.
This,
that shit.
It was so some serendipitous shit man.
Cause what it was,
I see a girl,
um,
Melissa painter did a video on me for,
I'm just company Wondros and um,
about about,
cause they found me on um,
on um,
the La Times.
So they came by,
hey,
find this guy,
do a piece on him.
So that,
so they did this piece.
And so one day I'm watching Ted and this,
the guy that did put the garden in the White House and you know,
he was real boring,
but I'm like,
damn,
this guy say the same shit I say,
but kind of white light,
you know,
and uh,
the same kind of shit.
And so I'm like,
Damn.
So I,
I emailed Melissa like,
well,
check this out.
Maybe you're right.
Maybe I should be teaching,
maybe I should,
because she's all,
you need to be teaching.
You need to be doing it.
I'm like,
I don't have a clue what the fuck I'm doing.
And I'm just,
you know,
I'm just doing it and making it happen.
And so,
so I sent it to her.
Okay.
So then,
um,
uh,
I don't know,
30,
40 minutes later go back to my computer and this,
this message on the computer says,
Hi Ron,
we've been watching you.
And I literally pushed my seat away from the table and I'm,
I literally,
there's nobody,
even in all,
I said,
what the fuck is up?
And I read Ted said something about Ted.
Dot.
We want you to come to Vancouver.
And I didn't even finish reading it.
I'm like,
yeah,
how hot.
Real funny.
So I sent Melissa emails like,
yeah,
you real funny dude.
You know.
Oh,
I sent it back to them though.
Who the fuck is Miller?
Who's Melissa?
That's what I get.
And I'm like,
yeah.
Right.
So I sent her on her email.
She's caught,
are you
[inaudible] have anything to do with it?
My air.
Right.
I talked to you and send you a Ted.
In 30 minutes later,
I'm getting invited to Canada to do tit.
That's how that should happen.
So they saw to her video on one of the guys who's now one of my good friends,
um,
nick wine bar.
He,
he,
he found a video online.
That's what he does for tech.
They literally scoured the Internet and different places and fine.
You find these stories and um,
that's how I wound up doing the Ted,
which was called the worldwide talent search.
They had never done it before,
so they literally went around the world looking for speakers.
And where I came in,
I was,
I was so last,
but I wasn't even,
even in none of the brochures because they finally,
then we got head,
his guy.
So I was the last person in the last city of the whole tour and I was the last
person on stage and I had never done that shit.
The four,
well,
you did great.
No,
no,
that was never done.
Let's see.
This one got me to that one.
Okay.
So it was like a,
almost like an audition.
I didn't know.
Yeah,
it was,
and I almost,
I said,
Brian,
you could just,
just leave,
just get on a plane and go.
You're going to embarrass yourself,
dude.
It's like,
leave,
leave.
You're gonna to embarrass your son.
Were you nervous?
Fuck yeah.
I was nervous.
Are you kidding me?
Well,
were you nervous?
Just public speaking as well,
the whole thing.
And being dyslexic and screwing up the lines that I thought I was supposed to
read and no one paid attention,
no one there.
They thought it's because they saw this video that was shot over its days.
They thought around,
we're not worried about you.
And I was looking at these college kids and these professionals and they have
these polished as pro presentations and I'm like,
Damn Dude,
how are you going to compete with them?
But why?
Why?
I wound up being the last one.
And I wound up getting a standing ovation that was in Vancouver.
So that's how,
that's how,
that's what happened to.
So I just let,
I literally,
I remember Joe,
my foot was about to hit the stage and I said,
dude,
you got to represent,
you gotta represent Yo son was,
you got to represent your hood.
You got to represent La,
you got to represent,
you can't come in this country and fuck up and right.
And when my foot hit the stage,
I literally still at the bullets forwarding gonna Fall,
you know?
And that in the end I went out in our,
our rock days.
I mean you,
if you watch it,
you can see the nerves kind of.
But if,
you know,
compared to my two big 10 big Ted,
that shit was just like,
oh,
I should change.
It's changed my life dude.
And a sense of,
from the moment I Gannon stays to the moment I went off stage,
it was just,
Eh,
it ain't stop.
I mean that,
that was,
I didn't expect that.
I didn't expect that kind of,
I didn't expect that dude.
I didn't expect people to react.
Like I didn't expect that kind of reaction.
Well,
it makes sense.
It all makes sense.
And you do a great job.
I mean,
what you're saying makes sense.
And you do a great job of expressing yourself in,
in a,
in an authentic way.
You are you on stage,
right?
You're not trying to be somebody,
you're not a politician who,
me too fucking good.
I can be.
No.
And I tell people don't change.
But that's good.
No,
it was,
it was an,
and I think that's what threw me,
because you hear hearing all these brilliant people,
all these academics,
and they,
you know,
when all these people would,
all these dudes,
you know,
letters behind their name,
Phd and all that Bush and then my remedial ass,
you know what I'm saying?
And it's like,
how do we do,
why are you even here?
God is,
that's authentic and refreshing to a lot of people,
like the people,
they're getting tired of hearing the same sorta land monotone.
You're being yourself and also your message resonates.
Like it makes sense to people.
But hearing what you're saying,
they're like,
yeah,
why don't we grow our own food?
Yeah.
That would be a great utilization of space.
So,
no,
when I saw,
I mean,
I got,
I got a massive standing ovation from there and it was,
it that,
that I,
it hit me,
man.
It was like,
whoa.
And I'm too in,
it just,
it just changed everything.
Wow.
It just changed everything in the end.
I mean,
I,
um,
I got,
I got mad respect for Ted,
you know,
I mean,
a lot of people are,
it's a call with,
it's this,
it's what I always hear.
I know you had,
what's his Eddie Wong.
You had Eddie,
I saw your shit.
Yeah.
Anybody that Eddie's rich and they're trying to make them have a roommate.
Right.
Was like,
can I get my own fucking hotel?
He could've got his whole fucking room stop,
dude.
He doesn't lie that he's not a liar.
Did they make you stay with somebody?
No.
I just stay by herself.
Maybe that's why they didn't make me stay back with a scared
little Chinese guy.
That motherfucker in the room with somebody else.
It's funny because I did,
I did this.
I had the best time.
I did this conference called mad for him.
Um,
you know,
in Copenhagen,
native Sepi,
who's the owns noma,
which is,
you know,
notice the best restaurant in the world.
And this conference was like all chefs and food writers,
like food people from literally all over the world,
man.
And I had a girl to come visit me,
she,
I met her there and she came,
visited me to,
to talk about a project and she says,
yeah,
Ron,
you,
you came out and you scared everybody,
you know,
but it was like you changed the whole co you changed the whole atmosphere of the
whole conference after you,
you know,
cause basically once I did my piece,
it wasn't everybody just fired.
Everybody just got naked if I get and just like let it hang out.
Yeah.
There wasn't none of that pretentious bullshit.
And she said,
but I said,
I scared.
What did I do?
She says,
you just came out and,
and you told people to raise their hands up and cause I did this thing for
Ferguson there,
you know,
and I'm like that.
I said,
Oh yeah,
the big black guy.
Ah,
you know.
So it's funny,
it's funny to hear that though.
I don't see it,
but,
um,
you know,
it's,
I,
I've had a lot of fun and I met a lot of great people,
but I've also this shit where,
you know,
I got people,
this woman and they want me to come to this place in Ireland and this is what I
get.
They want you to come and they're going to pay your fare and they're going to
put you up.
But they're not giving,
you know,
paper,
they ain't,
it ain't no honorarium.
Danes giving,
you know,
speaker's fee.
And it's like,
what?
You want me to do a keynote and you want me to do,
uh,
you know,
a panel.
So basically it comes,
it's almost like I'm entertaining your people
and they're paying to get into this conference,
may add money.
What the fuck is that?
Um,
you get that a lot man,
where it's like,
you know,
people were in,
I have to to end and shit,
so I get this shitty ass email just like,
well,
I guess no one else ans asked him for honorarium or fee.
So I guess this is not a fit for Ron.
Good luck in what he does at a diner.
And it was like real snarky kind of kind of like the nerve of you to ask us to
pay you.
Right.
But you don't do what you do for free.
This I send my kids to private school.
Well you know they have that south by southwest festival festival.
I keynoted I opened south by southwest eco last year.
I was the key.
I opened whole conference and they will never show my video.
I say something crazy.
No,
I mean I kind of clown.
I clowned him just about what we're talking about,
you know,
about,
about not paying people.
They offered to have me come down and they wanted me to perform there and uh,
do,
do some fucking thing they were doing on podcasts and they,
they offered me a pass to go to see and they're like this passage where $1,200
to see all these other fucking people who aren't getting paid,
they want or need a fly in on my own dime myself and pay for my own fucking food
and work for free.
And they were going to give me a pass.
I was like,
no,
and do you see how much money they make?
And,
and what I did,
literally,
I didn't go deep,
but I did kind of see,
I mean,
I told the whole all,
I said,
hold on a minute and this,
you know,
and I had a tip,
I had a bucket of friend,
a paint bucket,
and I had a sign assists tips.
I said,
hold on.
So I got the tape and I put tips on the bucket.
Then I got on stage.
People are fucking dying laughing,
you know,
some of the tweets were like,
oh,
Ron Finley just entered the stage with a tip bucket details later,
you know,
so and,
and I kind of clowned him about,
you know,
why am I here?
You know?
No,
it's,
southwest airlines is a fucking big company.
They have a lot of money and they're the sponsor of this whole thing.
It's called south by southwest.
They have a fucking southwest airlines plane on all their pictures and brochures
and shit.
Like,
where's the money going?
Yeah,
no,
it's,
but it's exposure.
Joe,
you need to,
I tell you,
you know what I say about exposure?
I said,
too much exposure.
Give you an ammonia,
your knife.
Frostbite.
Yeah,
exactly.
Tia.
Dude.
You know who's going to be in the audience,
Joe?
No,
I need a check,
dude.
Fuck who's in the audience?
You know what I'm saying?
So your response,
that's not your responsibility.
If you want me to come somewhere and you want me to inspire and do what I do,
I need to check because you're taking me from what I do and it should be
as well.
It's like the exposure should be as well as financial compensation.
Thank you.
It's like,
yeah,
there should be some exposure.
They should be able to say,
hey,
Ron will be able to pay your fee,
blah,
and here's a good thing for you.
It's exposure.
But the say that the exposure is your pay.
He was fucking ridiculous.
That's really,
I did get,
I did get a,
I did,
I think,
well they reimbursed me for my flight.
Aww.
How cute is that?
We remember.
That's insane.
It's insane.
If they're charging money for people to perform and the not paying the people,
I mean that,
that's one,
that's one of my things now,
so,
and everybody's,
and I want to send this woman a real bad letter just to say,
you know,
just like you don't do what you do for free.
Don't think that I'm supposed to be honored to come and speak on to pound on a
panel and keynote your event for free.
Just because you've given me a ticket
and it's a conference.
It's,
I mean,
it's just things festival.
It's sponsored by a major corporation.
It's fucking ridiculous.
It's profitable.
It's a profitable thing.
There's a lot of people that are working there.
They're all getting paid
to do what they do.
Exactly.
Then.
So no,
I don't.
And everybody's like,
well Ron,
and I'm like,
damn,
damn fucking scam.
It's 100% of scamp and people fall for it.
And apparently they pay some people,
you know,
they pay some people.
Everybody's getting the same thing.
Not really.
No.
Some people apparently get paid and that's one of the reasons why they keep it
very high profile.
You know,
big bands and shit like that.
They get a certain amount of money is,
but it's the,
I don't know how those things got started,
but when they offered it to me,
they offered it to Dunkin first.
My friend Duncan trussell's,
a very funny standup comedian,
but at the time Dunkin wasn't very well known and you know,
and he was like,
wait,
do you want me to fly there and work for free?
So he made a video about it using that,
the Hitler speech,
I don't know if you ever see the Hitler speech where people do this a video,
it's just been a month,
a hundred of them made of Hitler ranting and German and the titles of what he's
actually saying it was Hitler going off about south by southwest,
making people work for free.
It's fucking crazy.
It's crazy.
It is.
That is a God damn huge.
Huge
when that's just one of them,
man.
And a lot of them have a lot of them do that.
And it's like I've had,
I've had so many,
so many,
so,
so much.
Well,
so much for the movement.
Oh,
you want you at your feet so much for the movement.
Whoa,
whoa.
It's like,
what do you mean what I'm supposed to do?
What I do?
I'm supposed to fly to you and in,
in,
and work for free.
And it's because of this.
So what you call it a movement.
Well,
but meanwhile
it's not like there's no money.
That's what's ridiculous.
It's one thing if this conference was free,
everybody can attend for free.
If they people donated food,
they donated hotel rooms every,
oh,
everybody's working for free.
Okay,
but that's not what's happening there.
Check this fucking thing that they sent me where they said,
ah,
you know,
hey,
we'll give you a gold pass.
It's worth 1200 bucks.
Like,
Whoa,
whoa.
What the fuck did you feel insulted by that shit?
I was laughing.
It was hilarious.
So you want me to go there and lend my recognition or my town or whatever and
you're going to give me a fucking pass?
Yep.
Oh,
good Lord.
No,
I get it.
I get in it.
They'll try,
I guess,
you know,
I got a cup of festivals to try to do that.
And I know,
you know that.
Um,
it's like,
I mean,
I know that the,
I have in this game,
you know,
they put me on this thing,
so I have on this kind of like,
oh,
Ron Finley,
you know,
to me,
I'm still,
I tell people,
it's like I was in England and I,
they put me,
has this cathedral and shut shut Phil.
And they put my,
they had my,
my,
my picture,
like,
what do you call it?
Projected on the whole cathedral.
So you walk up and it's bigger,
you know,
the Pope Pitch,
I'm like,
Damn.
And so,
and I told her,
I got,
I said,
damn,
you guys must be bored here.
It's like seven o'clock on a Saturday and you're here to see me.
And it's like,
how do you even know who the hell I am?
And some woman yells,
her famous and I said,
yeah,
my dishes still need to be washed,
you know,
so it's like youth,
I'm not famous to me,
you know?
Right,
right.
I don't know how there was conferences.
You know how you deal with that festivals?
It's not that hard.
It becomes like your reality shifts.
But I don't know how these festivals got away with that business model.
I don't know who the fuck let that happen to many each year.
Trick.
Yeah.
Too many eager people that don't understand their value.
Oh
yes,
yes.
You said it.
And that's exactly what it is.
Oh,
I got a book to promote.
Ooh,
I got this.
if so and so's going to be there,
I heard he's going to be there.
Ooh.
And I'll be up.
That's exactly what it is.
You don't have,
they don't have a value now.
And that's what I,
and that's my whole thing with this thing.
And in Ireland you're,
you're,
you're insulted because I know I have a value.
So you,
you,
that's what it is,
man.
It's like people,
they I need to get somewhere.
It's cause I have this product,
I need to get somewhere because you know,
and if I,
if I do here and then I'll go there and that's,
that's what it is.
Right?
It's the south by southwest.
Rene's people that they claimed that all the money goes to charity or anything.
I have no idea.
I've never heard of that before.
I have no,
I don't think so.
I mean,
we're complaining too much about something I think,
but the,
the,
the idea of you not being compensated for it like that,
it's like,
oh so much for the movement.
That's fucking insulting.
That's insulting because they,
you know,
they would never say that.
Well that was,
that was some cost.
Some organization back east,
I don't even remember who they were,
but that was the email.
Once they tow,
this is his fee and this is what he gets.
And that's what I got back.
And it's like,
people say,
well,
aren't you a nonprofit?
I'm like,
no.
My nonprofits,
the nonprofit,
I'm Ron Finley,
he needed,
he needed a check.
How the fuck you supposed to pay your rent?
How the fuck am I supposed to fill your gas tank?
It's,
people are weird,
man.
People are weird.
They're weird with how they look at other people and fairness,
you know,
and,
and especially someone who's legitimately got something that's important to say.
And somehow or another,
if you've got something that's important to say,
you should be doing it for no money
is that,
well I think it's that whole Mother Teresa Shit.
Or You have these kids coming out of college now that have trained in no profits
so,
and they have them thinking that you're doing good so you don't have to have,
you shouldn't get paid that law,
you know,
there's not money to pay you.
But the,
the executive this run is like you said something about one of these
corporations,
it's morning where the money is and cross the Red Cross is where the money,
yeah,
he's probably getting,
you know,
a couple of million dollars,
but the people on the ground,
same thing with one of the,
I don't remember if it was a good wheel of one of them where they were paying
people like a quarter or somewhere at hand because they had,
but some writing where they could do some ridiculous ass price.
They were paying people that were working there,
you know,
handicap people in different shit.
So it's like that just because you,
it says in writing that you can do that.
Does that make that shit right?
You know,
so,
so in that,
and that's,
that's,
that's where I'm at with it,
man.
I don't,
I mean I do a gang of shit for free,
a gammy and I was growing putting in gardens and everything for free.
You know,
my thing,
a lot of times people don't respect that.
I think you need a value on shit.
Well,
especially if they're charging money to hear you speak right.
That's where it gets ridiculous and you realize that they're making profit off
of it.
And that's,
all of those organizations are making profit.
That's why they exist.
I mean,
even Ted,
Ted has become this huge business,
you know,
and without a doubt they do benefit because I enjoy Ted talks.
I found out about you through Ted talks.
I've watched them all the time.
I was watching one today on fucking the engineered proteins that are causing a
different food allergies and you know,
and,
and how antibiotics and foods and all this different shit and all those things
are incredibly educational.
All those speeches and Ted talks are fascinating,
but once you start
getting money,
once money becomes a part of the thing.
You know,
people start trying to maximize the profits and people still.
But I mean like what Ted,
I mean Chris is a lot of these guys,
they started out rich,
he bought ticket from,
you know,
from another guy.
So I mean he,
they got paper,
you know,
but I,
I don't,
I think it's,
it gets to,
you know,
a penis show.
I got more paper than you watch what I'm [inaudible] it's like,
uh,
but,
but I mean,
I got mad respect for Chris,
you know,
I mean,
the fact that they let that,
they let people use the tabs and it's like,
oh damn,
this is like open source.
It was like,
like with a Ron,
you want this,
they'll call you want this person to use your tag for it.
They want to put it here.
And I'm like,
yeah,
cool.
So it's like they give you that,
that kind of consideration.
And for you,
the more it gets spread,
the better.
Right.
The more people,
the more people talk about the more your ideas come out there.
I've had kids,
I had,
one of the coolest things,
man,
is I had these kids to,
this father sends me pictures of his kids.
They're probably like 10,
11 and um,
they're calling themselves gangsta gardeners and they send him pictures of them,
like growing,
like propagating plants and seeing,
he says in the recruiting area,
you know,
other gangsters from the neighborhood to grow food and this is an Indian.
I'm like,
you know,
if a friend of mine was,
we used to work in Africa and in the Bush he says,
this guy said,
man,
this guy probably has a wooden computers,
so fucking,
oh,
you know,
so he says this guy's rides a bike 20 miles to use the phone and he hasn't heard
from him in years.
And all of a sudden he's like,
hey mark,
you work in south central,
right?
There's this guy,
you should find him.
You know,
his name is Ron Finley.
I saw him on Ted and he's in.
Mark says,
Dude.
And once he tells me this story,
he was like,
Yo,
he just shaking his head.
He said,
dude,
this guy lives in the bush.
You know,
so you know.
So it's been crazy to me.
Oh my God.
Well see what happened.
It's too untethered.
It says 2 million.
I don't know,
a couple of hundred thousand.
But what that doesn't count Joe is when people see it at a college.
When people see it in a school room,
when people see it in,
in um,
in the auditorium,
when they see it at the movies cause it's showing a movie.
So those,
those people are not date,
those numbers are not co are counted.
So it might be an extra million or 2 million fucking easy.
I mean cause you think like with,
with um,
my video was probably one of the most,
when you do a Ted x,
you have to show a ted video.
And my ted literally has been shown probably one of the most around the world.
Like when they do a tedx because they sit in,
you know,
the people say,
Hey,
we just watched your video.
we just watched your video and you know,
in Amsterdam or what not,
you know,
in the Middle East and shit like that.
So the numbers are pretty staggering.
But what,
what you,
what really hits me is people go to action.
You know,
there's a guy saw my video in Brazil and um,
you know,
he contacted me,
you know.
Yeah,
yeah.
Next thing I know,
like a couple of,
uh,
like a month ago,
he's on the news in Brazil and they s somebody sends me the clip where he says
he's talking me up in Brazil.
Like,
yeah,
we,
oh,
we took this lot because of the Ron Finley and soft syndrome,
you know,
the other than it's like,
whoa.
So that kind of Shit it,
that touches me,
man,
that this word,
I don't have to be there.
That's the whole thing.
People we need none of,
no,
you,
me,
dude,
I don't need to be there.
You are me.
How many years has it been since this all started?
Since the first Ted in Vancouver first tip was 2012.
So it's only been a little more,
which matters.
Yeah.
The,
and it feels like six.
I mean,
no,
it feels like easy.
I swear it's,
I,
when I look,
I cannot believe what's transpired in the short,
very,
very short amount of time.
And the,
one of the biggest things that the law has been changed,
you know,
to,
to allow you to grow food on your parkway in Los Angeles.
Uh,
I,
um,
it's,
to me I'm humbled,
you know,
that,
that it's,
that it's happening like this where kids are calling me,
hey Ron,
we're in Boston.
We don't have the green spaces,
but we have,
we have roofs.
How can we take your project farther?
You know,
so,
um,
that kind of thing.
You know,
this kid in Texas where it start planning food on his front yard and all his
parkway and he calls it his front yard,
dock yard,
grocery store for his neighborhood.
Wow.
So,
I mean,
that kind of inspiration,
Joe has been just been like,
you can't,
who could have thought this man?
You know,
I,
I w I wouldn't have thought that,
you know,
I got kids from Oregon University coming,
to see my garden or kids driving down from,
I'm from up north to work in my garden,
just hey.
So it's been,
it's us almost like,
um,
some,
cult shit.
I don't know.
It's like we want to meet you,
we want it,
we want to touch the soil that you worked in kind of thing.
You know?
So it's amazing because what you're doing is like such a basic normal human
thing to do that we've been doing for thousands of years.
And that's why it still astonishes me that
it's people who are putting this on.
I see why when I hear the conversations and when we see where the world is
because it's almost like,
oh yeah,
I forgot about that.
I can do that because we don't have no skin in the game.
Joe,
you,
you go,
you talk into a box and you drive 20 feet and then they hand you a box of shit
that supposed to be food.
You know what I'm saying?
And you drive off and you took the good,
there's no skin in the game.
And I think that's why.
So that's to me is like part of the whole slavery shit.
You know,
it's like you're,
you're a slave to that rhythm.
You're a slave to that because now you don't,
that that's making you weak,
um,
that you're,
you're being controlled now you're gonna it's like the monk pushed the button
and you know the Pavlov Dog Shit,
you know,
ringing the bell and you start salivating.
Well,
I think there's a movement going on right now and you see a lot of different
places in our society where people realize,
hey,
we are live in exactly the same way our parents lived.
And as we get older we realize they didn't really know what the fuck they were
young.
So everybody steps back and says,
Hey,
maybe we should exercise more.
What kind of exercise and should we do?
Maybe we should do shit that people have been doing for thousands of years.
Strong man,
type shit.
Do dead lifts,
do squats.
That's where this whole crossfit things coming from.
What is it coming from?
When people realize that if you lift weights,
you feel stronger.
If you feel stronger,
you feel better,
you be healthier.
Okay.
What about food?
People are realizing,
hey,
you know,
you're not supposed to feed cows.
Corn,
corn fed beef is fucking bad for you.
Hey,
I'm going to eat grass fed beef.
Hey look,
the fat in grass fed beef has actually higher and essential fatty acids.
It's better for you than meat is healthier.
It's a healthier animal.
That's why it's leaner.
Okay,
what's lead?
Let's see,
let's eat that more.
Hey,
organic vegetables are probably better for you.
Let's fucking eat more organic vegetables.
And he'd see these fucking whole foods and Arrow ones are popping up all over
the place and exorbitant rates,
exorbitant.
And people like.
And then people like,
Hey,
you know what?
This fucking dirt right here.
Why don't we grow our own shit?
So it seems like this is part of this movement of realization and you are in
that you're a part of this movement of realization.
Yeah.
This show is a part of this movement of realization.
We're all a petition because this show is connected to the Internet and there's
no,
there's no network behind it.
There's no person's telling us what to do so we can have someone like you on
just because we want to write.
Because it's interesting because it's an interesting conversation and then more
people are tuning in.
They know there's no agenda and they go,
oh,
this guy is telling me I can grow my own food and he's not even trying to get
any money out of me.
It's just trying to tell me to grow my own food in my backyard.
He's telling me about compost,
he's telling me how he got started just simply to spread the information
I saw.
I just saw sickness,
man.
You know,
you walk out your door and you see sickness and it's like,
and then when you go somewhere else and you see the same thing and it's like,
damn.
And that's when I came up this,
this is why as well as this parallel.
Why is this the same?
You know?
So we have to take that,
we need skin and again,
and it's like,
that's why my whole thing grow your own shit.
You know,
and not,
you don't have end,
like you said,
you don't have to grow everything yourself.
Right.
But if you do it collectively with your neighbors,
that's what I'm talking about.
It's like where you grow in the apples and the,
and the carrots and Sally down the street is going some chart and rhubarb,
whatever the hell.
So now you've,
you can't trade food and I can send my son to Yo spot until Yo give me some
carrots to Joe's house and that's,
and vice a versa.
You know,
you can send them over to my house and get some onions.
That's what I see,
man.
That's,
that's what it was.
So you have eliminated a couple of systems and you've created community,
you created partnerships,
you create a business without,
without a money exchange,
you know,
and,
and you've created safety,
you know,
so,
so that's,
and it's so damn simple to me and I guess it's going gonna take me away.
It's so simple.
It as like you,
but you guys know this,
right?
You know,
you want,
you're not talking about something that's like,
just been discovered,
some new technology that has recently been released to the public.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And that's,
it's,
that's why as to me,
it's still somewhat mind boggling,
you know,
100% mine boggling.
And what you said about community as giant,
because I think people live in this weird place now where we barely even know
our neighbors.
You know?
And the more populated areas are,
the less likely you are to know your name.
And that's what I'm saying.
That's where the safety comes in.
Cause I know,
I know your son and I know he shouldn't be doing that.
And I know he said,
wait,
Yo dude.
So I know.
You know,
so that's what,
that's where the safety comes in.
Right?
And that's where,
that's where the neighbor hood and that's where community comes in and that's
what caring for one another comes in.
And,
um,
it's,
to me,
we can do it,
it can happen.
I mean it's,
there's too many,
there's too many examples of this happening now
are all our whole system like packing all these different people into these
small areas and not knowing each other.
It's so alien to human culture for thousands and thousands of years.
We've known all the people that are in our tribes.
Yes,
we all have these groups.
We,
we help,
we help each other.
We have,
you know,
hunters and gatherers started out and then they developed agriculture.
But everybody worked together.
But now we get these weird things where we have cities,
we have a big concrete box and we stuff a fucking thousand people into it and no
one knows anybody.
It's weird man.
It's weird.
Well,
I mean,
yeah and I,
and that's why I tell people gardens,
they build communities,
not just food.
And it's like people with,
you know,
I've had these,
people come to that Wah Wah,
so how much food can you grow on a piece of land this big,
you know,
talking about the parkway.
And I'm like,
I really don't give a fuck.
You know,
I don't grow food.
I grow people.
And sometime they grow food.
It's not about the food.
Food is probably three or four down the,
the list is what you get from that.
Soils,
which you get from being involved is what you is what a child gets from,
from from learning.
Okay.
From touching the soil,
from seeing that I planted a seed and now there's this big ass treat.
It can feed me.
Oh.
And it's got value.
Just the stuff that this tree has hanging on,
it has value.
So look at all the lessons that are in that soil,
you know?
So that's what it is to me.
And then it comes and then it comes to food.
But,
but if you're not exposed to this ever at all,
you know,
if you just want your hot Cheetos and Takis and that bullshit,
it's like [inaudible].
That's,
to me,
that's,
that's condition.
It is.
We can change the design of these neighborhoods just by that,
by changing the people.
And there's something in our,
our genetics,
our DNA,
our,
our spirit,
whatever it is that like really gets rewarded from growing your own food.
When I picked vegetables out of my garden,
I make a salad out of them.
It feels great in some weird way.
Don't you think it should taste better?
I didn't know.
And you think you think is you?
You think it's like my babies.
They're the prettiest,
you know,
you think is one of those things.
But I remember when the first time I had successful watermelons,
man,
I had these watermelons that,
and I taste,
I'm like,
God damn,
I ain't never tasted in my life.
Tasted a waterman like this sign.
I gave some to neighbors and it's like they thought I injected the watermelon
with something.
You know it's sugar.
Yeah.
They don't like no dude.
I'm like,
no,
really hair.
And I've never been able to get that back.
But I thought it was one of those things.
This is my,
I finally got this watermelon watermelons to grow in their,
the best ever.
And it was,
I've never taste nothing like that.
I used to have this orange tree in this house that I rented in and see no,
and they were the most fucking delicious oranges I've ever had in my life.
To this day.
I've never had an orange that good.
Wow.
I would pluck them right off the tree and they would be so juicy and sweet.
I can't,
you buy an orange and the supermarket,
it just doesn't taste as good as those oranges off of that just natural tree
with no effort.
I never put fertilizer down.
I didn't do shit.
It just grew oranges every year and they were amazing.
Nature happens.
Yeah,
that's what that's,
that's what I'm saying is that that tree is going to do what it's supposed to do
with very,
very little effort
and we also fuck up the flavor and the nutrition and things by making them last
longer and supermarkets on the shelf and shit lack on some shit.
Putting shall lack on them and even just engineering these vegetables to last
longer.
When you do that,
like tomatoes,
my grandfather used to have this garden in Newark,
New Jersey,
and I don't know why New Jersey is famous for tomatoes.
Yeah.
Something in the soil or with the seeds or whatever it is.
But they would have these tomatoes that like you've,
you've,
you've had heirloom tomatoes,
they taste so much different gonna fucking tomato that you regular tomato that
you get from a grocery store just like no oil and hard.
They'll like from these tomatoes that kind kinda a little bit mushy to them.
But when you slice into them like a fruit and you realize tomatoes are supposed
to taste like almost like a fruit,
our fruit,
they're delicious.
And the ones that you get,
like if you buy a burger from Mcdonald's,
you see that Pale ass fucking tomato slice.
That thing could leave live for a month on a shelf.
And that's,
and that's why it's to me,
what is that?
What's happening to this food?
This food doesn't even,
you know,
get back.
It doesn't even get mold on it.
Right.
You know,
so that's a problem.
That means it's not alive.
And it's because they want this shit to be delivered into these neighborhoods
that aren't growing anything.
And they want it to last in the trucks and last in the shelves so that they get
the maximum amount of money out of their effort out of what they put into it to
grow them and to ship them and to,
to house in the supermarkets.
So we've developed this food.
We,
we've sort of developed this food that accentuates the system.
Yep.
Yeah.
No,
we in that,
in,
that was my whole,
my whole thing is like,
I guess waking up realizing,
Damn,
I've been bound bulls it all these years,
you know,
thinking that,
um,
you know,
they don't care about us,
and it's like the fact that the government led a lot of these laws be our past,
you know,
regulating this shit and,
regulating this,
like the fact that,
oh,
we don't,
you don't need to,
it's fine.
You don't need the label,
this bullshit.
What do you mean?
Can Can,
uh,
can I know what's in my food is why,
why is it,
you know,
um,
I'm not cool with that,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
I think what you're doing is really interesting and I think that's one of the
reasons why the Ted talk has been viewed online countless millions of times and
people have seen it in schools.
And the reason why it resonated with me,
what you're doing is it's so interesting because it's such a normal thing,
but in talking about it,
and especially you're a charismatic guy,
when you're on stage and talking about you're being yourself and you're,
you're,
you know,
you're having fun with it.
And when you're doing that,
it kind of gets everybody titillated and excited about it.
And then it spreads this movement and I guarantee this podcast is going to do
more of that too.
And it's also something that's really accessible.
Like when I talk about hunting,
people go,
yeah man,
but I can't fucking Mohan.
I don't have a gun.
I can't get that horse.
That's a higher,
as a guide.
I'm going to move to Montana or something.
It's fucking,
and then you don't know what you're doing and want to shoot anybody.
You gotta learn gun safety and a hunter's safety courses,
vice president,
your ex vice president,
fake.
She never quite got there.
But yeah,
yeah,
it's,
it's difficult to get your own meat,
but man,
growing their own food is pretty fucking accessible to a lot of people are more
accessible than you would.
Thank.
And to me it's,
it's,
it's sexy as hell.
Yeah.
I say,
you know,
somebody said,
oh,
somebody wrote me once.
I said,
you know,
I tell these guys,
I said,
because of the,
the guys,
I was a man.
Ron,
why,
why?
There's always these girls at your place,
man.
Why,
why you always have,
I'm like,
I told you guys,
if you plant flowers,
you get flowers.
You know what I'm saying?
So I'm like,
you better stop playing in this soil,
you know,
and they didn't listen.
I,
I ain't doing that until they see the girls then.
It's a whole nother thing.
And,
and I,
I said some of this stuff,
somebody sent me a email,
oh,
Ron.
Ron said this,
this was a real sexist,
um,
remark.
And I said,
you know,
I said,
you want to know are true panty dropper is when you go to your garden and you
pick some food and you cook a meal for a girl or guy.
But because I asked that Bourbon in it,
oh,
that,
that's sexist.
Why is that sexist?
I mean,
it's like,
who wouldn't want,
I mean,
that's sexy as hell to me,
dude,
that you can go to your garden and fix a meal and,
and feed it to somebody.
I mean,
come on,
that's win.
Went well.
People love the call sexist.
Yeah.
You're not,
you're not discriminating or diminishing women and is that way by saying that,
but did he just
love bitching and complaining?
Tell me how you deal with that shit.
How do you deal with,
with people thinking just because you're a public figure and you're entertainer,
that you're out there and they can just,
they can just,
you know,
and they got your email,
that dress or your fucking Facebook or whatever it is,
and they can just say shit.
And they think it's cool because they're on Facebook,
they just want attention.
That's okay.
Is that,
you think that's what it is?
Yeah.
A lot of it is,
and then they're,
they're short sided a lot of it.
And sometimes they have good points.
You know,
sometimes people have points and you have to look at it from their perspective.
Yeah.
I think they,
you know,
it's hard to be that low on the ground though sometime.
Yeah.
Joe,
the Cedar fucking respect.
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's hard to not be affected by things that people say about you because in real
life when someone says something to you,
it's a conflict,
you know?
But there's no conflict.
There's no real conflict online.
And that's the reason why they're able to do that with no recourse or rather a
no repercussions.
And also there's no social cues.
There's no interaction.
They're not in front of you calling you a sexist piece of shit.
Because if they were also,
you would get more than just the printed word.
I know to get their personality you would get,
they'd be like,
oh you're fucked up.
I see what you got your own problems.
You need to worry about why you worried about me being sexist?
What I'm talking about vegetables being size head.
I've had,
you know I've had a couple of interactions and some I said,
Oh Ron,
I think you need a PR
person.
She's fuck off.
You don't need a Goddamn PR person's,
I'll go,
don't check me and think thank you.
Checking me just cause you don't know who the fuck you really don't know me.
You know at all.
You don't know what I stand for.
You don't know what I do.
This is a part of me that you but don't think you can just say some shit in and
like Kinda just kinda judge me and go at me and just cause you,
you,
you online.
And it's like no.
And some occasion and I've bit my lip a lot man.
But it's like right now they make it real hard to do good.
You know what I'm saying?
And this should be,
it shouldn't be.
No,
I'm not even gonna.
I'm just saying that just the system the way it is with a lot of this nonprofit
bullshit and this,
that's what it is.
Just that it's bullshit.
A lot of it,
a lot of his bullshit man.
And it's like,
are you,
are you guys really trying to change some shit or a Ron is this money comes with
strings.
What a noose.
What kind of fucking string,
you know,
what are you talking about?
It comes with strings.
What are you,
are you trying to change this or what do to do just that's some bullshit.
Oh,
you got to shuffle papers and it's like,
and that's what I'm trying to,
I mean,
I'm trying to literally see change too.
And I mean it ain't,
no,
it might be some eagles shit in there,
but when I do something,
I put my fucking foot in.
Dude,
I want to see some big massive,
ginormous type shit changed man.
And that's,
that's what,
that's what I'm the,
and it's like whoa.
And you getting to talk to these people and getting,
going to and trying to get money,
man.
And it's like you realize you guys ain't really trying to change shit.
Well,
some people are and some people aren't in the real situation.
You're dealing with this as the are staggering.
You know,
you're dealing with,
when you're online,
especially with your online like you are and you become a celebrity because of a
cause that you support.
You are a person who can be reached by other folks who agree or disagree and
just the sheer numbers you're dealing with people like you can't filter them
out.
You don't know them.
You can't meet all 100,000 people want to comment on your fucking youtube video.
You can do it.
You don't have the time.
And if you did,
you wouldn't even get to know them anyway.
You get to know the,
you know what they're putting out there and they're fucking most polished,
most prepared version of themselves.
You don't know whether or not they're really,
they have their shit together enough to consider their opinion.
So you don't know when you're getting the printed word in someone's responding
to you or insulting you or criticizing you in some sort of a way.
It's hard to deem whether or not it's valid or not.
So it takes a certain amount of personal sovereignty when you're putting,
you know,
I split it in me.
I don't,
I mean,
if somebody said,
Ron,
you shouldn't read all this shit.
You shouldn't.
And I'm like,
I read it.
If it's there,
it's coming.
I'm reading everything.
It doesn't bother me.
There's certain shit that people could rate.
I mean,
I've been trying to bother you.
Oh No,
no,
there's Oh day.
And I tell him and I read that Shit and it does not bother me.
You know what I'm saying?
I know who the hell I am.
I have a code and that's what I live by.
I'm not living by your code of what you think should happen.
So I'm,
I'm,
I mean that kind of people like you shouldn't read those.
I'm like,
why not?
Yeah.
Why not?
Yeah,
no,
I,
as long as you're cool with it,
why not?
Yeah.
I always say that it's like snake venom.
If you get too much in one shot,
you're going to die,
but if you have a little every day,
you know you become immune to it and I could read mean shit about me and I'm
like,
that's not true.
I know me,
I know who I am and I slept with me last night.
People I was pretty damn good.
They also like the people that are criticizing you.
Do you turn that high powered perspective,
the introspective like analysis?
Do you turn it on yourself?
Do you do you do judge yourself the way you're judging other people?
Most likely not.
And if you did,
you'd probably shut the fuck up because you have plenty of things in your own
backyard to clean up before you go after other people like Kim Kardashian or
these fucking people you're,
you're getting upset about online.
Go to any video online and read the comments on Youtube.
99.9% of those motherfuckers leaving comments she had just get away from the
computer,
get their fucking life in order.
Like you're,
you're missing,
you're putting all this effort and energy and it's someone you don't even
fucking know.
Trying to make them feel bad because you feel bad that they're rich and famous
and dating Kanye West or whatever it is.
I had,
I had somebody say something cause I used to post pictures of 'em and I still
do.
If I see one of people with tattoos,
I don't have no tattoos and you know,
but I still appreciate the art of it.
And the beauty of it in the fact that somebody did this in the,
the of that shit.
And I would pells tattoos and some woman,
you know,
pick me up and says,
oh,
I was surprised to wake up this morning and find this on your feet.
You being a progressive fucks that I'm a progressive and I don't,
what do you see here?
A woman in a bikini with tattoos and what did I see?
Art.
I see art and beauty here,
but she,
you know,
the fact that somebody thinks that they,
like you said,
it's like,
Oh hey,
I got a tight right.
I can see the computer,
I can do this shit.
So you do have to,
you know some,
okay.
Yeah.
Well people love to categorize like I'm a conservative,
I'm a liberal.
I'm a in the end,
if you don't,
you know,
you have this rigid ideology that falls into that.
Oh you're a progressive.
But yet you like girls.
Like what the fuck is that have to do anything?
How about these girls?
It's their choice whether or not they want to take photos with bikinis cause
they liked the way their body looks.
And there's not,
it's not bad.
What people don't like is the way it makes them feel about their body.
We see a woman who's got this fucking bang and body and she's got a beautiful
tattoo on her back.
She's sticking her ass out.
Whoa.
Sexism.
Oh No,
she's all right.
She wants to do it.
She wants you to see that ass.
Cause she know she likes it.
You know?
Oh,
exploiting women.
How about she's exploiting you?
Stupid.
How about that?
She's got a fucking great hand of cards.
That genetics delta,
she went to the gym every day.
Look at that ass.
Oh,
you know.
it's a sexy.
No,
you're fast.
You don't like you're fat.
You don't like that.
It makes you feel like shit when you look at someone that works.
I didn't call you fat Joe,
coach.
Some people are fat.
It's a damn fact.
You can't get away from it.
And the San people that will think that you're egotistical because he'd go to
the gym.
Uh,
well how about you Ken?
And it makes your body look better and feel better.
And people,
people are more attracted to you.
That makes sex better.
Nobody wants to say that.
No.
Sex is about I love.
Yeah.
Guess what?
Love when you're more attractive is better.
No doubt it is.
It's this better.
If someone has a good body,
there's a reason why they use women's bodies to sell cars and fucking shampoo
and everything.
It's because we're attracted to it.
And if your body is overflowing with neglect and fucking,
and you're,
your fat rolls are pouring over the side of your underwear,
that's not as attractive.
Some people fucking shit sexy though.
Some people to find that shit.
Sec.
People like ugly feet turn off from ugly feet.
Necrophilia you're right.
I'm being closed minded.
Yeah,
you are.
I'm a,
that's a little,
a little,
a little judgmental.
I'm very judgmental.
So I do for a living.
I just shit people say don't judge.
If he didn't judge what,
I never get anything done.
You would be fucking hit by cars every day.
You'd never judged where the cars are coming.
We were retarded.
Don't judge.
But that's how we got to here and fucking 15 okay.
That's how we got,
we've been judging shit or figuring out what's good and bad.
You know,
it's don't judge.
No judge.
People don't like the people don't like the fact that there's this abroad
fucking range of human beings in this life.
And some people got lucky as shit,
you know?
And some people like just athletically.
Yeah.
There's people that no matter what the fuck they do,
they'll never be Coby Bryant.
It's impossible.
He got a way better genetic roll the dice and you period,
end of discussion,
move on with your life.
Maybe there's some shit.
Your baby,
you're a better singer than Cobie.
Maybe you tell better jokes.
Maybe you could write a better book.
Maybe you're better at eating pussy,
but whatever it is,
whatever it is,
you can't shoot a jumper like that's his.
He got that.
Sorry.
It is what it is.
Your nose is bigger than Mariah Carey's.
You got to deal with that.
This is the hand that you're given and you know,
but people don't want that.
So they go,
oh,
look at you sexist.
I thought you were progressive.
These photos of women,
what?
I didn't need the progress.
It's a new new label.
People love labels.
They love being a part of groups.
They look,
I mean the new one is social justice.
Why the fuck did I get put in that group?
Well,
because you're a guy who was teaching people how to grow vegetables.
Oh,
that makes that sort of aggressive progress.
Isn't that going backwards though,
isn't that you're right in a way,
but it's progressing away from the direction that we're at now,
which is negative,
which is factory farming and factory agriculture and all this fucking bullshit
with the meeting antibiotics.
That's negative three education progress is moving away from the chemicals that
had been put into our foods for greed and profit.
So that makes you a progressive.
Also anybody that is against racism,
anybody that is against a government monopolies and corporate control of our
media,
that's progressive as well.
It's just,
there's just labels.
People love labels.
Wow.
So,
okay.
So does it make me a progressive that I'm tired of him shooting these black kids
and getting away with it?
That shit's progressive.
Progressive,
very progressive.
Well,
I think that,
um,
what we're seeing today,
and this is a really interesting time when it comes to accountability for crimes
that,
especially with the police,
there have been more articles in the past year that I've written that I've read
and that I've seen online and more videos and more protests about police
brutality than ever before.
And then finally,
what's the response?
La just paid for 7,000 body cameras that cops are all going to be forced to
wear.
No,
that is accountability.
And that is a direct response to people being outraged and that's progress.
And that is a,
that's being a progressive,
oh,
it's somewhere they got some cop,
I forgot where it was,
Texas,
somewhere where he would just,
he would,
um,
just arm what you call it,
disarm is his body camera and do
some foul shit.
You know,
they kind of beating up some girl.
He should go to jail.
They should be a mandatory like 20 year prison sentence for a cop.
That disarms is fucking camera on purpose to do something like that.
Like you are,
you're committing a crime and you're abusing your position of power and you're
doing something that is absolutely not what you're supposed to be doing.
What he's supposed to be upholding,
protecting,
serve and protect does not mean take your fucking cameras,
shut it off of,
beat the shit out of somebody because it's illegal there.
No.
Well how about that fucking guy that was in Denver that was beating the shit out
of this guy?
That was on the ground,
punched him in the face.
They saw a guy with a camera that was filming it.
They take the guy's camera away from him,
delete the pig,
the video arrest him.
But he had already sent it up to the cloud.
Right?
And so then he released it online and now everybody's like,
well,
we're all about accountability,
right?
We're all about transparency.
Fuck you are the fuck you are.
That guy knocked over,
a pregnant lady was punching some poor immigrant dude in the face.
You know that happened?
Yeah.
The guy was selling a little drugs.
Why is he doing that?
He's broke and poor and there's a bad situation and if you lived his life,
you'd probably be doing the exactly the same shit he's doing.
It's in,
it's in.
It's so easy to do.
I mean,
and like I said earlier,
where it is,
the drugs come from.
How the fuck did they get here?
Yeah.
What I'm saying?
Yeah,
I'm in.
The reason,
the number one reason why they're sold,
the way they're being sold right now is because the factory illegal.
That's why if you look at Portugal's decriminalization of all drugs and you look
at the amount of people that have died,
the amount of crimes that have been committed that a drug related,
there's a graph that that was put up online a couple of days ago,
that it's a fucking huge dip,
a huge dip and drug related violence,
a huge dip and all sorts of shit that's connected to illegal activities.
When you have illegal activities,
look,
alcohol in this country is a huge problem for sure,
for sure,
but you know,
it's not a huge problem.
Alcohol companies shooting other alcohol companies because they're stealing
their profits because the fact that it's legal,
you don't have that gang on gang violence that you're having done in fucking
Mexico.
That shit is directly connected to the illegality.
Do you want all these motherfuckers on the street?
Hi.
I don't want him drunk.
Yeah,
how about that?
I don't want them driving drunk.
We got drunk and I would want
way rather have people driving around on marijuana than driving
around on alchemy and of course go to Texas.
But I didn't like though when I'm not Texas.
I mean Denver,
when I wasn't,
when I was in Colorado.
What,
what wasn't cool?
They were just smoking in the street and somebody whose kid is right here.
I didn't,
I'm not cool with that.
Literally booked me in a bud and breakfast hotel dude.
But I've never been high a day in my life.
You know what I'm saying?
And I'm like,
what?
Why did they book you in that?
Then I then maybe they got a special rate.
I have no idea.
You know,
I don't know what the hell that was,
but it was like,
you know,
he just assumed you get high,
you got to cool.
Most people do.
But that's probably what it,
maybe you would be even cool if you've got hot,
not a day in your life.
I mean,
look,
I never a couple of,
I'm never
that I find to be
that Joe,
some comedian did this joke about him.
What?
He says I'm gay.
I couldn't imagine I'm not gay,
you know,
suck another man's Dick.
And he says,
what?
Well just that once,
cause I needed a ride
ride home.
I got to do what you gotta do.
That's what I did.
You're selling drugs.
I've never had a cup of coffee,
dude.
Have her in my life is awesome.
I had so I hear,
you know,
don't ask me why gets you.
Well look,
there's not,
you don't have to,
obviously you turned out great.
You don't need any of these things.
You don't need alcohol,
you don't need drugs.
You don't need any of those things.
Okay,
well my point is that they exist and some people find them beneficial and grown
adult should be able to do what ever the fuck they want.
I enjoy a cup of coffee.
If coffee was made illegal,
I would be fucking furious.
Like,
yeah,
if like some asshole decided that coffee is somehow or another causing people to
be too tense or be more productive or whatever the fucking reason they decide to
make it illegal,
that's a grown adult telling another grown adult what they can do with their
life that doesn't affect anybody else other than that.
So yeah,
it's bullshit.
You're one of those coffee lead people that have to have the certain brand type
shit and no,
no.
I go to Starbucks all the time.
Oh God.
Go to fucking Dunkin donuts.
They're shitty coffee.
I like coffee,
but I like good coffee.
It's like anything good.
Coffee's better.
And my friend owns caveman coffee,
which is a single source coffee company,
has a direct relationship with his farm in South America.
They grow the coffee,
he gets the coffee,
they bring it back to America,
they roast it.
It's like,
you know exactly where it came from.
He has a direct relationship with the farmers.
That to me is beautiful.
That to me,
you know,
going,
you go down to Central America,
you get the fucking coffee.
Yeah.
You know,
you know where it comes from.
I like all that.
I like that.
You know,
it's very difficult to grow coffee in America.
And in fact there's a place in Santa Barbara,
I think he's one of the few places in America that's grown coffee.
It's not that easy to grow it in America.
You need a very particular climate.
You know,
I,
one of the things I found out,
I had a guy on who was a,
a coffee expert who told me that all coffee is actually from Ethiopia.
All of it.
Every original originally from Ethiopia and all this coffee.
Do you have like Colombian grown and all that shit?
It's not supposed to be in Columbia.
They brought it over,
they brought it like Arabian coffee,
Arabica beans.
All that shit came from Ethiopia and they brought it to Saudi Arabia or wherever
the fuck they're growing it,
all of it comes from me field.
Well that's one of the things with me with um,
native plants.
You know,
it's some of that to me is some bullshit native when,
when was it Nate,
when you know,
and that's this big thing.
We're only plant native plants here.
Native when wait year food,
who said it was Nate when the dinosaurs were here?
How,
you know what I'm saying?
What the fuck was it native to you dude?
And you got these scholars and they preach this and it's like native when I
won't give me a date.
Right,
right,
right.
Well,
there was an episode of Radio Lab,
which is a great podcast on the Galapagos Islands.
And I was talking how there's all these invasive plant species that come from
literally dude's walking somewhere else,
having something on their shoe and then walking into this new place and then
these plants grow.
It's a native now it's native down.
Yeah,
right,
exactly right.
And that crazy.
That is crazy.
It is crazy how we like that native and way we do it with humans.
That's where it gets really weird.
Like if you're over there like especially my,
what?
I was tripped out,
I talk about this when I go to San Diego all the time,
cause I love San Diego.
But one of the weird things about San Diego is it's right now he's still a t o
Mana and those fucking people,
they can come over for a little bit,
but you get better,
get back over and your fucking side.
Like they'll let people come over.
I'll go,
let me take the papers,
check your papers.
Okay.
All right.
You know,
you're only over here for a few hours and get back over that fucking line.
I think there's a line for human.
It was literally aligns that crazy guy with a gun standing to making sure many
guys,
many guys with trucks.
The fucking trippy thing about San Diego is they got you drive like 40 minutes
outside of San Diego.
They got another line to try to catch you just in case you're hiking someone's
trunk.
It's fucking nuts,
man.
No,
I,
it was that sign.
Do you notice sign has got the family and the little kid is dangling behind
everybody's running.
I'm like,
that's just look so racist,
dark,
dark.
The fact that you got to be careful that families are trying to come over here
for better life and that's why they're coming over here.
They're not coming over here to rape dogs or fucking
being in Mexico too though it it let me know that a lot of that shit seems like
propaganda because when I was in Mexico,
it's like Guadalajara and places,
man,
these people are like not even thinking about coming to the states.
I mean,
come on,
man.
They're like,
it's nice we kick in it or eight restaurants.
Great Nightlife.
Yes,
but they have the thinking that this whole country wants to come to United
States.
That's the propaganda bullshit that we get.
Like the whole country is lined up waiting and they're not.
Man,
there's people just having shit over there and you know what the,
one of the weirdest things about Mexico is is the border towns that are the most
fucked up.
Yeah.
That's so strange.
I got a friend,
I got a friend painting right now in Juarez.
That's a bad spot.
I am on my own Mac.
I heard he was in the Walrus.
That's a scary spot because the weird thing is you cross war as and it's fine
and America is fine.
San Antonio is nice.
You know this about what?
I don't know.
That's not good though.
That's weird.
It's weird.
Tiawana there's another one.
I mean Tiwan is not as bad as everybody thinks it is,
but every now and then they'll cut a bunch of people's heads off and leave them
in fucking garbage bags when he notes tied to him and shit.
I mean,
they will do that.
so far it's fucked up.
It's fucked up.
Yeah.
I mean,
that drug violence is fucked up,
but that shit didn't happen when we were kids.
Right.
That shit is all within the last 20 years.
Yeah.
I mean,
I went to Mexico without a second thought in,
I think it was like 2004 or something like that.
I went on vacation there.
It didn't worry at all.
But in 2014,
10 years later,
it's like,
whoa.
No.
We were in,
um,
uh,
teach an Eatsa,
went down to see the,
the,
uh,
Mayan Pyramids.
Amazing.
That's a trippy shit.
But it is now people,
you know,
you talked to people about going to Mexico and they're like,
fuck that.
I'm not going down.
They're fucked up.
It's,
I mean,
I think a head cutting.
We'll do that to you though,
Joe.
Well,
how about Chicago's gang violence?
I mean it's more people die in Chicago every year then a lot of these cities in
Mexico and we don't think about that.
When we traveled to Chicago and everybody just goes to food is so fucking good
and kind of town and not think about Sinatra songs
call.
I was in Chicago and somebody like Ron,
if we need your help,
we,
it was one guy,
I think he owns 60 lots and it,
it looked like some de militarize.
It looked like some war zones.
Such shit man.
It's like,
and they're like,
we want,
we need to plant food,
we need to,
and I'm like end to see that somebody owns 60 lots and this is normal.
That wasn't like he was some special guy.
How is,
it's kind kinda crazy in Chicago man,
that that is happening like that.
Yeah.
Well there's some crazy spots in this country for sure.
I mean Detroit,
I spent some time in Detroit last year that trip me out when you buy a house for
500 bucks.
Yeah.
You know,
in Detroit is starting to slowly bounced back from that to where people are
starting to.
People are starting to them start businesses and she's starting to expand and
starting to make use of the land.
A lot of the artists are going out there to,
you know,
it was,
I guess,
I guess it's like the new wild west out there.
Well in a lot of ways,
I mean the,
the nature has sort of reabsorbed a lot of the buildings.
Like there's,
there were some uh,
nature does that shit.
Fuck yeah,
it does really quick,
really quick.
She don't play,
nature doesn't give a fuck about your rent and your zoning.
Nothing.
But there was a website that had all these homes in Detroit that are being
reclaimed by trees,
like trees growing through the center of the floor boards.
He's building,
like there were some holes in this,
in the ceiling,
which is enough to let rain and light through a seed got somehow or another end
of the ground and it's grown through the fucking floor boards.
There's a tree in the middle of a house.
That house won't be there in a hundred years.
It'd be a fucking tree,
you know,
and it'll,
all the boards will rot away and the tree will absorb the,
the,
the nutrients from the rotten wood.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
It'll be like compost for this tree.
No
doubt.
And that's,
that's it's a Ma.
And I tell people,
you know,
nature always wins.
Always ask.
Those people were in palm pay if you can find them,
you know,
nature nature had no play in nature does not play.
And we in the,
and I think that's what we need to hear that call.
Cause the way we fucking up this planet because it's,
it's,
it's a thing where,
um,
we have history to see what nature is like,
okay,
you guys are done.
You know,
it's like you can't keep just screwing this up and think it's going to be cool.
we,
it's like they had a,
it was it.
Sure.
Novo or one of those other nuclear places where they did a show,
I think it was 60 minutes or something.
They went to visit one of these places and it's,
the radiation is still off the hook.
They'll be forever where people cannot live in this.
It's just like,
this stuff is frozen in time to turnover.
I know exactly what you're talking to me.
And then they said what they said in the nuclear actor,
there's actually like mushrooms and shit growing up.
Yeah.
I wouldn't eat one.
Right.
You probably know if somebody told you true,
oh,
you'd be all over that.
She gave me on the next plane to turnover.
I would,
uh,
let somebody else eat it first.
Now we're closely monitor them for a few years.
I want to make sure there's not some sort of an incubation period.
Eat that mushroom and six months later you become one.
Like,
have you ever seen those mushrooms?
Like there's a strain of quadriceps mushrooms that affects ants where it grows
inside.
The ant,
kills the ant and then it literally explodes and spray spores all throughout the
colony infecting all the all ads.
So these ants,
when they find out one of the mushroom or one of the mushrooms has got ahold of
one of the aunts and killed it.
They take the ant deep,
deep,
deep into the woods and drop his body off and get the fuck out of dodge.
Like they have a bomb.
They have to get away from it.
It's almost like instinctively nature has let them know that there's a certain
amount of time.
Yeah,
this is,
these is ants that are growing these mushrooms out of their bottom on Matt Stop.
Oh,
it's a trip dude.
And that mushroom that grows out of the body will explode and the spores will
spray into the air.
And in fact all their shoes and tha tha tha aunt like soy or,
exactly,
exactly.
And they're using it as a base to launch all of their soldiers that are gonna
affect all the other aunts was crazy.
Dual nature.
So crazy.
There's so many examples of them using like other bodies as a host to spread.
I mean,
it's like you learn or die and that's what it's telling those ants.
You better figure out how to get this funding body and drop it off in the woods.
That's how do it.
If I like an ant attacks on animal,
uh,
or or bug in another insect,
how do these group,
no.
Okay go dude.
You get the right.
I get the left.
I'm going to get the,
I'm going to get that head.
And how do they know that?
We
don't know.
We don't know how they know,
but we do know.
They do know.
Do you know that ants,
takedown elephants?
I didn't know that.
They climb up the elephant's leg and start eating their fucking brain from their
ear.
They climb into their ear and they let somehow or another let all the other ants
through pheromones or,
or whatever signals they send.
They let all the other ants know,
hey,
we got some food here we go.
And they will climb up the fucking elephant into its ear and start eating the
elephant all alive from the ear
brain first.
Fuck.
That's kind of,
that's kind of a little tiny thing cause nipping away slowly at an elephant guns
all day.
We don't,
we got time.
That's the thing about it.
My friend Brian wanted to be a biologist at one point in time.
He wanted to work with insects and he was in I think new Guinea or some,
some jungle.
They had a,
they have these tents that they would have to place on platforms above the
ground and then they would put Turpentine on the street on the posts to keep the
ants from climbing up because once they find you,
they fuck you up.
Bio Mass of ants,
the biomass of ants on this planet,
like the amount of weight of ants is the same roughly as the amount of weight of
people.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's true.
That's somebody fucking ants.
There are,
that's crazy.
That's crazy.
7 billion people.
At least a hundred pounds.
Right.
Did you see that documentary on ants?
Um,
where they hit this guy hit,
he wants to see how big the colony was.
Oh,
I did see that.
He poured the concrete in and then they pour some more concrete here and then
they push them.
Then they got to kind of keep to concrete truck.
Then they got another concrete truck and it should just kept taking them all the
concrete.
And I think it was a square mile or some crazy shit.
And they dug it up.
And this was this aunt
there,
whatever the hell they call them,
leaf cutter ants.
And they,
they,
they not only do they have this incredibly complex system,
but in it they have ventilation because these leaves,
these leaves are decaying.
So in order to give these leaves air so that the fumes from these leaves can
escape,
they created fucking ventilation systems.
That's insane.
Talk them this who
taught the man who taught,
they say answered the only one,
only species that have pets because like a fits,
when you have a fits on your plants,
they bring the aphids basically to your plant and then they milk them cause the
aphids suck the,
um,
the sugars out of your plant.
And then they have these little things on tobacco,
like titties and they,
and the ants get the milk,
suck that out of them.
So they literally,
it's like there's their cattle or some shit.
Fuck,
I had some,
like I have these,
the bees and they were in the front of the hive and they were,
you know,
crowded.
And I'm like,
what the hell is happening?
So,
and I'm like,
what did they have?
And they were moving.
And so all of a sudden was,
no,
there was,
it was a rubber band.
It was a rubber band that,
that because when we put the frames in,
somebody that kept the rubber bands on them to hold up the,
um,
the wax stuff.
And I'm so the,
the ants like,
get that Shit Outta here.
So these,
I'm saying to bees,
literally drug these rubber,
cut the rubber bands first and drug them out and then dry.
I got pictures of this and then drop them,
like flew a little and then dropped him and then even moved once the thing was
on the ground and moving them further away.
So I'm,
and I got,
I got this,
I'm like,
what the hell is happening?
And then,
so I saw all the rubber bands,
so it was like eight rubber bands that they did this to.
Wow.
And it's,
it's,
it's like I got some brilliant shots of it and you,
you,
it's like hot.
And so you've got aunts pulling this side of the rubber man ans pulling that
side of the rubber feet.
How I keep saying bees?
Yes.
Fascinating.
So did they affect how it's suspended?
The
guests?
They let,
I guess it was up already when they did it.
That what they were like,
Hey,
do this thing,
we ain't about this,
get this rubber band.
No,
I mean,
I don't want to what it was,
but you could see they literally cut the rubber bands.
Wow.
Yeah.
So it's,
there was pretty,
uh,
so it's a lot that I think we have to still have to learn that we don't know.
Well,
I've told the story before on this podcast while I told you,
um,
one time when we're doing fear factor,
we covered people with bs and we had this dude who was a beekeeper.
He brought in his colony and you'd cover people with bees and they had to stand
there and covered with bees.
Well,
while we're doing that,
we were doing it at this ranch.
And,
uh,
local colony showed up.
That wasn't even the one that wasn't his.
And so he had to back away.
He told everybody,
we got to shut down,
we got to a local and they got to work this out.
So we had a backup and get out of the way.
Big Gang fight.
And the local bees and his bees communicated with each other.
They didn't fight,
but they were in the air and they were fucking swarm.
And you can literally see,
you can see them.
We see the two different clientele.
He couldn't tell,
no one could tell,
but they could tell.
And the,
the local colony left and his colony came back into his,
you know,
his,
those hives,
those things that he carries around with them,
those,
those trays that looked like filters for an air conditioning system,
you know,
and they had to work it out.
They worked it out for like 20 minutes,
half hour,
whatever the fuck it was.
And then they took off and they're like,
what the fuck are you guys doing here?
Oh,
we fell in a show,
you know,
like they had to have a conversation.
I had a like,
why are you guys here?
Who was these foods?
So what happened to the people that were covered with bees?
Where they covered already or no,
it was in between.
Oh,
we're transitioning.
So it was lucky.
And when these be showed up,
the one shows up and then a bunch showed up and then a whole cloud of 'em showed
up.
I'm glad you brought that up.
How many people did you guys kill him?
Fear of you right there.
We've got lots of shit.
What do you think would kill people and just buried himself?
Where a certain way or something.
I covered them in Kim tries.
People doing,
dude,
what?
Just took that?
We sprayed them over the city and they control the population.
Mine control.
Hang in somebody over in a car.
We got lucky and ocean is shit.
We could have killed people though.
No.
Shinde
you know the scariest thing wasn't even there.
The scariest thing that I ever saw was riding bulls when they wrote,
when they had people road ride bulls.
I was like,
that is fucking God damn crazy.
Like that scary shit.
Like those bull you can't print,
you can control,
you can have like a really good system of safety harnesses and all these
different things in place where you could be reasonably assured that if you
engineered a stunt correctly,
the people are going to be fine.
That would have been not what a bowl.
You can't control shit.
That was the scariest one for me.
And when that was over I was legitimately terrified all day and then it was
over.
I was like,
cause I was scared someone was going to get stomped or someone was gonna get
kicked in the head or any of those things can happen.
I'm sure you've seen those videos.
Where the fuck yeah,
those bulls like you know what,
I'm about sick of Yo ass and go into the audience and Gore.
Oh yeah.
I've seen him do that.
A bulldog in where they grew up with it by the horns in Mexico.
Again,
testosterone.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
Just like the fucking rooster.
He put testosterone it on.
Nice cow.
Cows are sweet.
They don't want to fuck with anybody.
Give it to a bowl and then you start fucking running at you with their head.
The testosterone makes them grow weapons on their fucking event.
Crazy,
crazy.
They grow weapons on their head that they can stick through your asshole and
launch you into the air.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It's crazy.
But yeah,
so that,
that is the,
no one ever died on fear factor.
And it's one of the reasons why I was happy when it got canceled.
I was like,
you've got a whole,
we got away with it.
We got away with it.
Listen,
Ron,
it's been a great fucking podcast.
I really am.
I talking to you.
Thanks for inviting.
You have a nonprofit.
How can people contribute?
How can they donate?
What can they do?
Where,
where do they get ahold of you?
Uh,
info@ronfinley.com.
It cover everything.
You can buy some t shirts,
you can donate some money.
We got a,
um,
a crowd riser,
but just Info Ron Finley or hit me up on the website.
Ron finley.com.
Ron finley.com is the website.
And you have a crowd risers that we just said.
Is that like a crowd rise fund me type thing?
Exactly.
Yup,
and what happens with that money and where's it going?
We were putting it into work.
We got this actually we got this hell of a project we're working on.
It's the oldest operating library in the city and it's right in the middle of
the hood.
It's called the Vermont Square Library.
It's got an acre behind it and we want to just put the,
we want to put up a space there that has gardens,
but also a container cafe made a container greenhouses and just a creative space
where people can come,
do mosaics,
learn how to cook,
eat a healthy meal and exchange fruits and vegetables and have a weekly food.
There's a lot of Shit's gone.
That sounds beautiful.
I want to contribute and I want to help you out.
I want to promote it on Twitter as much as possible.
I think what you're doing is beautiful.
I appreciate that.
I really,
really appreciate being here,
man.
I really appreciate comment.
I had a great time talking about,
let's do it again.
We'll do it again.
Okay.
Damn rounds here again.
No,
no,
no.
I enjoy this very much.
Ron Finley HQ on Twitter.
Follow him.
Sent him some love.
Send him some money.
Be a part of this and help out.
Thank you guys.
Joe Rogan experience.
All right.
We'll see you soon.
Okay.